e
my name is Bob har I have the honor of
being your chair for this session for
the resources Recreation development
committee I welcome everybody to our
orientation our committee researcher is
next door with the clerks in their
training so we don't think she's going
to make this training representative
Dunn who was on the committee last year
is our clerk he's being trained he did
some clerking last year but he's next
door so he'll be joining us when they're
done at
10:00 uh can I ask you all to please
rise I always start every meeting with a
Pledge of Allegiance please join with me
in a pledge to our flag I pledge aliance
to the flag the United States of America
and to theic for it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liy and
so just as a start and a point of
business representative Sergeant you are
going to be in charge of the blue sheets
for the next session so and I will
forget and representative Veil used to
always remind us but at the end of the
session if I don't ask you could say
would you like the count from the blue
sheets and just give it and also the
person on the end not that you were
stuck there intentionally
um when we have witnesses come in they
need to fill out a pink card and it
usually starts with you and then just
pass them all down I need the pink card
so I can arrange the testimony so the
pink cards and the blue
sheets and I will talk to you later
about a security issue so before you
leave come see me
okay um it was asked if we could start
on my far left which is representative
sergeant and maybe give your name who
you
represent um an interesting question was
did you ask to be on this committee or
were you just assigned uh and any
passion thing you might have or hobby or
something so we know a little bit about
you and where you come from so we'll
start with representative sergeant and
okay uh yes yes thank you my name is Tom
buo I'm a representative from Conway
Carol County District number one um and
I I also asked to be on this committee
because um locally we've just done a new
uh master plan for the for the town and
um priority is protecting the aqua
for and and and I and I I thought that
um knowing about the issues that come
before this committee would be
helpful
I'm representative Susanne Vil and I'm
here from
Nashua um yes I did ask to be on the
committee this is my third term on
resources um and I'm here because I grew
up in state parks I was a fresh air camp
kid and I was born to a family that that
did everything they could to protect
clean water in our city so thank
you hey I'm Linda Gould from Bedford New
Hampshire this is my sixth uh time on
resources and definitely I asked for it
I'm a dedicated bicyclist I've bicycled
around the world different places not
not around it but different places in
the world and I've hiked and kayaked and
everything enjoyed the outdoors yeah
thank
I'm Heather Baldwin I'm from thoron
Waterville and Ellsworth I did ask for
this committee I was on this committee
last
time for 50 years I've lived on a 100
Acre Farm that's surrounded on three
sides by National Forest in the White
Mountains um it's near and dear to my
heart and even though my district has no
water bodies other than the pem jaset
river flowing by we have no Lakes we
have no anything this is a good
committee for me to be on and I'm glad
you a representative Arnold Davis I live
in
milin uh I represent myin all the way to
Pittsburgh and uh I asked to be on this
committee this committee actually is a
good fit for a hick from Coos County so
I'm Alison NAB I represent stratum which
is over between exitor and Portsmouth on
the Sea Coast um last term I was on
environment and agriculture but I did
ask to be on this committee don't tell
them um I served with Arie last last
term and um I just felt like it would be
a good fit for me I'm on my town select
board and I serve as the recreation and
Conservation Commission liais on there
um I work with the Great Bay stewards
which is the friends group to the Great
Bay National EST and research reserve
and we also have a peass issue in my
town so uh I was interested in this
committee look forward to serving with
you all
hi my name is representative Tanya
Donnelly and this is my second term on
this committee and I have to say I
really enjoyed L and I said yes I want
to do this again um why I even got
involved as a State Rep is because I was
concerned about pasas and W water
quality issues because I live on a water
supply in Salem so I'm representing uh
the Salem town of Salem uh and so I
worry about canaby Lake worry about our
Arland Pond I worry about all the
different lakes and that we have across
uh New Hampshire so that that's my
here hi I'm Linda Ryan from nsha I um
did this is my second time on resources
and I'm a retired science teacher so it
seemed like good fit I'm also a former
nashwa uh good morning my name is
Nicholas Bridal I'm a freshman rep and
this is my first term and my first time
on this committee
uh I represent Hampton Beach I had the
privilege of growing up on Route 1A and
seeing the aisles of schs from my
bedroom for the first 20 years of my
life and uh the beach has a pretty
special part of uh my passion so that
you good morning um I'm will Derby I'm
from nsha definitely uh this is my
second term and I was on resources last
year as well as fishing game for one uh
one year um I asked again to be on this
committee because I'm on the
Conservation Commission in Nash I'm on
the energy and environment um Committee
in nsha I have a camp on lake monomac in
ring uh and I am also a uh an avid
Outdoorsman uh uh bow hunting in
particular but also fishing and whatnot
fit I'm Brian Taylor also a freshman
representative I was born and raised in
Carol County and currently represent
eight towns in the county which is also
known as a Lakes Region and uh I've seen
enough of the world which uh I think
I've got a great appreciation for what
we have in this area i' like to uh keep
our way of
life well thank you all it appears
everybody wanted to be on this committee
so so I better not say I
didn't now this is my uh fourth term on
the committee I served about three years
as Vice chair I'm from plastow I
represent plasto Newton in Southampton
New Hampshire and similar to the
representative to my left plasta was one
of only two towns in the entire state
that has no standing body of water so
you might ask how do you get involved
with resources well uh I'm a real estate
attorney by profession and as a real
estate attorney we deal with a lot of
development water supply subdivisions
also
disclosures um so I thought that would
have been interesting during my first
term to be and I asked to be here on my
first term also I'm on equestrian uh H
ride Prof show um do a little bit of
trail riding so the trail riding and the
groups I belong to got me interested in
this because we're in charge and we work
with the trails and the forest and um so
uh we did have a couple of bills few
years ago about horses on trails and all
my friends showed up we had about 200
people come to a herea all equestrians
so that's how I got involved in this
committee um I'm always proud to tell
people that this is a
very friendly committee um I mentioned
everybody probably about 90% of all the
bills we passed they go on consent um H
and they said how does that happen and I
tell them it's kind of hard to vote
against cleaning water good supplies
against past to protect the country and
our state and that's the kind of stuff
we deal with and they go oh uh and I do
understand there'll be some bills that
we don't agree on but we all work
together and I'm looking forward to all
of us working together for the best of
the state which I know everybody's
concerned about make this a better place
to live for our children and if I don't
mention this today my wife who's
probably watching uh from New Jersey
Jersey will shoot me uh I this morning
about 4 hours ago I became a grandfather
for the second
time and my daughter had a grandon a
small baby boy 7B 12 O I'm not sure the
height yet but I'll find out that later
pictures are coming um so uh his name is
Oliver so I want to get him on the
record for the first time in his life
Oliver keki you're on the record of the
State of New Hampshire and I hope maybe
someday you might be governor who
knows so just to let everybody know I
our as I mentioned earlier our
researchers next door with the clerks um
so she may not come in on time our
committee assistant has been with us for
a while Jamie Wyman
um I've already scheduled for next week
six
bills um we have 10 on the docket and I
expect we're going to get 10 or 20 more
um and although they now have a rule
that we can list uh the opportunity to
exact a bill without at any time I'm
going to you're going to notice that in
the calendar I'm going to put that in
every time but it's not my wish to
invoke it unless I have to uh so
exacting bills will be published and
listed unless there's something that we
need to do time
constraints um I don't know when our
first exec session will be I need to see
the next week how many more bills we got
in if we don't have a lot of bills for
our third hearing then I might have a
short exact session in the beginning at
10: and then move on to some bills if we
have a lot of bills a lot of FNS a lot
of second committee bills we'll have
another day a hearing and then probably
the next meeting we'll have some exec uh
we'll work that out with um
representative NAB and everybody will be
given notice of it um so nothing will be
a
surprise and
um so that's how we're going to schedule
if anyone has any questions they can
email me I don't mind average highing my
direct email is just my name Bob harb
aol.com so it's kind of easy to remember
my name Bob harb at AOL.com if you have
any questions or want to make me aware
of something it's always easier if you
send it there than as you know the
legislative email where we get 7,000
emails and I got to dig through them and
try to find yours um I think we're going
to have a great year these bills the
first 10 bills are very interesting um I
think uh people are interested to come
testify and we're looking forward to
hearing from them uh does anybody have
any questions or anything they' like to
bring up before we start at 10:00 with
hearing no
jeez it's like I feel like I'm a teacher
in school is anybody have any questions
and nobody has any um yes sir if no one
has any questions have a procedural one
on the pink cards would you like them
one at a time as people come in and fill
them out or one pile all at once if you
see like like right now there's three or
four people there filling them out you
can wait until they're done then pass
them up okay um if there's only one
filling them up then send them up
because I put them in order with the
clerk and he needs the cards for the
record um so I'll know who to call up
next and the blue sheets are at the end
against and I don't know if we want to
check Arie do you want to go see if
Jamie wants to come in we got five
minutes I'm going to ask if our
committee assistant wishes to come
in she's the assistant for the committee
if you think we need something it always
helps if you ask me and just say Mr
chair do you think we could have the
assistant do something to to accumulate
uh something for us rather than 17 of us
giving her
questions uh also I have asked her this
time because although I know we all know
how to print and we all know how to put
things together this year I asked her
when she sends out the notice can she
PDF all the bills we're talking about in
one PDF and send them out to us so that
you can print them all together and she
did that for the first four bills she's
going to do them again for the next six
because then you don't have to go and
print them one at a time and compile
them together I thought and she goes oh
that's easy I can do that so I thank
Jamie for that for the first time we're
going to see it again so if you don't
read the bills in advance as they come
in you'll get them with the package of
the notice of the hearings so all you
got to do is download the whole thing
and then you'll have time to look at it
since we meet on Wednesdays and unless
something happens I continue to meet on
Wednesdays um we have to schedule I have
to schedule the next week's meeting by
noon time today so usually by Tuesday
night I send in what we're doing because
we're busy here so it's like I don't
want to forget so the schedule for the
next week will be in by Tuesday or
Wednesday Wednesday morning for the
following Wednesday so you'll have a
week's notice of what's coming on but if
you just went to the committee and put
Bills currently in committee you'll see
the 10 bills four we're doing today six
were I schedule for next week if
overnight it went up to 11 then that's a
week yes ma'am Mr chair maybe you said
this to your new people but do you want
to say anything about the drawers and
how people can store things out there or
use that room yes so we shared this room
with another committee so the other
committee asked if they could use the
desk I don't use a desk so I said yeah
you can use the desk so if you go out in
the committee room you'll see a set of
draws that look like plan draws that you
pull out and you can put a plan in them
um your name's on the
draws very rarely will be the things in
the draw but sometimes somebody will
drop a bill off they might have some
test Mony and they just fill the drawers
um that's your draw if you want to leave
something there that's okay but it's I
won't say it's not secure but it's just
a draw uh but you can check it every
meeting before you come in and maybe
when you leave I can tell you I usually
find it empty but um that's your draw
because uh the constituents always ask
me do I have a room do I have a desk do
I have a private secretary I say no I
got a draw
I got a drawer out in the in the cabinet
there and and I actually had to look CU
last year since I was vice chair I was
at the top drawer and now I'm
alphabetical so I thought they forgot
about me so I had to go down the list it
is
alphabetical um so if you look you'll
find your draw look in it I don't think
there's anything in it there's no
welcome gifts or anything it's just you
draw any other
questions I'm just waiting for Arie to
10 and for the new people when we
schedule a bill like the one at 10:00 I
can't start it at 1 minute to 10 I can
start at 10:01 I can start at 11:00 but
I can't start it before the time it's
listed so it's important
that and the reason we uh schedule these
in between is people have things to do
um so we don't want to schedule them all
the same time and they're here all day
to wait to testify at 3 in the afternoon
and there is no magic to how much
minutes I put between the bills I just
basically say gee how many people do I
think are going to testify and my guess
might be wrong I might think one
person's going to testify on a bill and
there might be 10 so this is why I can
start a bill later because of overage of
the first bill before it but I can't
start it
early um this week I scheduled them a
half an hour a piece next week they're
scheduled 45
minutes and if they go over they go
over we usually like to start at 10: and
the last schedule hearing would be
around 3: so that you could plan if you
want to plan your life we try to get you
out of here by 4: or before 4 four so
you can get home um and like today we
just started with four bills so we're
going to do them I'm not going to break
for lunch because if we have some
testimony that brings us over I I just
want to finish the four bills and then
everybody will be dismissed what did she
say in the cler oh she's in the cler but
she'll be here in after okay so our
committee assistant is also in with the
clerk's meeting I guess they take
precedence over us cuz
our house clerk reminded me yesterday
that he's in charge of all the clerks so
he has precedence over over me and
us um so it looks like it's 10 o'l with
past so I'm going to officially open the
hearing on HB 1113 relative to ohrv
operation on certain highways within the
you thank you Mr chairman and good
morning
everybody I'm representative ré culcom I
represent Hillsboro Windsor antrum and
Bennington uh over the summer I had some
Windsor residents approach me to see if
we can get some help to uh allow them
some legal access to a small portion of
um State Road that they have in their
town if you're not familiar with Windsor
it's a pretty small town uh there's one
Road in and pretty much all the town
roads that go into Windsor are in
Windsor are dead end roads they're dirt
roads uh this the little portion Which
is less than 2 miles of State Road is
the only paved Road in town everything
else is Dirt Road in town and Dead End
roads the Selectmen of the town have
given the residents the authority to
ride their roads with ohvs ATVs and utvs
are legal on the roads in
Windsor so as it is now it's very common
when when I'm driving in there to see
the ATVs or the TVs as their primary
vehicle when they're moving around town
to get their mail or whatever they need
to do the problem is is we have on this
map that I shared with you a small
section of State Road that actually
divides the town so the people on one
portion of the Town actually cannot
legally get to the other portion of town
to visit family friends or whoever um on
their
ohvs unless they travel the state
road because this is part of our um RSA
in order to give them legal Authority on
that portion of the road to travel back
and forth we need to put this into the
RSA so this bill is hopefully going to
be as simple as that for us to be able
to get through um on the map you'll see
that um I identified where the Hillsboro
Windsor line is and there's 8/10 of a
mile of State Road that's summer
maintenance only that travels down to
black p uh black Pond Road and there's
another 9/10 of a mile on black Pond
Road that's that's state maintain for
summer so they would like to have access
to this one so that they can continue to
move around their Town they're not
looking to open up an ATV Club they're
not looking to have um there's no trail
system over there so it's not going to
draw in a trail system there's no Club
that's organizing over there um this is
you know theoretically this is for the
the local use to be able to continue to
use their Road system uh the Selectmen
so far are in favor of this they are
still working through their public here
ings uh so they have been aware of
what's been going on through the entire
process I've given them their
responsibilities to make sure that they
have their public hearing with uh
notifying their Butters um so far the
feedback that I'm getting there's
roughly 12 houses I should say that too
there's roughly 12 houses that's on this
path of 1.8 miles uh and so far the
feedback that I've received is all
positive from the residents Hillsboro is
a pretty small town they have 275 re
residents according to our meals and
rooms tax
population uh they only have 11 kids in
school 152 of those residents are
registered voters so they're primarily
adults that are in this town um small
population of children so um I you know
again when they approached me about this
and I looked at the situation being an
active uh member of a ohrv club uh I
identified there's not a dust issue this
is these are paved roads so it's not
going to increase dust they're already
traveling on their town roads without
complaints or issues or um any negative
results to the to the selectman so
that's been going on for years I talked
with the police Windsor does not have a
police department so they rely on the
state police however when the call goes
to the state police the state police
calls Hillsboro Hillsboro responds to
the to the accidents or any um issues
that are over there and I talked with
our police chief in
Hillsboro and he he has no issues with
this in fact Hillsboro has their roads
open to UTV travel and he said over the
course of the last three years he's only
had one accident that he's had to um
tend to with a UTV on our roads in
Hillsboro um
so hoping that you guys would consider
passing this and I'm happy to answer any
questions you might have I missed any of
the
details thank you than you any questions
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question can you just
clarify for me does the Department of
Transportation have to weigh in on this
because it's a state road like why does
this Authority exist with the select
board or the
legislature the select board first has
to have their public hearing
to make sure that they are following the
wishes of their people so that is a
requirement under the process of the law
that exists the do
um will probably want to weigh in on
this the do can grant access to cross
the road if there's Crossing but in
order for us to have um traveling on the
state road it has to be incorporated
into the RSA and forgive me because I
did not write down the RSA number I bet
it's on
this RSA
25810 section 4 um specifically has to
have the listing of the town in the
road based off my best
understanding representative Davis thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question I'm just curious the speed
limit on this 1.8 uh mile par solo land
25 M an hour going in and I believe
there might be one small section that's
35 mil an hour but I'm not confident
that I'm right on that and if you notice
on the map it's a pretty straight shot
the the line of sight is pretty clear um
so they have they don't have to worry
you thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question representative and
just um trying to make sure I understood
what you said um that the uh Selectmen
have approved use of uh ohvs on other
town roads but there still debate
discussing um approval for these state
roads is that what you said they have
approved uh ATV and ohrv well ohrv use
on all of their town roads they cannot
and are not authorized to Grant access
to the state road however in order to
have this bill passed they have to
notify the abuts they have to hold a
public hearing and then they can make
their decision whether or not they're in
approval with
this knowing what I know unofficially so
um we do not foresee that there's going
to be an issue with this knowing that
there are some people on this route who
are asking for this so they they are
under the RSA they're obligated to hold
public
hearings and I met with them last night
and so far everything's going well
representative
ghou uh are the roads paved or not I
didn't catch that I'm sorry can you
repeat that are the roads paved these
two they are the only paved roads in
town are these sections of the um State
Road and just maybe one tenth of a mile
going when Windsor Road comes in and
tees off there's about a tenth of a mile
to the right that's paved and then the
state road going to the left which is
black Pond Road is paved for uh one
mile thank
you
representative thank you um as I recall
that seems there's a Sim similar
situation up in gorum where these the
ohvs come out of Jericho park and go
down the stay on the roads and go in
through town is can we get any
information on on their experience with
that I guess that's a
question not of the speaker because I
don't know you wouldn't have any
information on that I don't have
specific information but I can tell you
that I I've ridden up there and there's
a trail system up there so there is kind
of 1 Point to to another point there is
no trail system in in Windsor that is
managed by a club there's there's no um
there's no draw over there so being The
Treasure of the Kentuck Valley ATV
riders we manage the trail systems
through henker into Hillsboro but we end
at a certain we end at a restaurant in
Hillsboro and in their in their ballpark
we do not go further west into this area
so there is no organized Club in this
area to manage Any Trail systems there
is north of the town but they already
have access to everything in that area
now as it is thank you there's no draw
for tourism I should say there really
isn't in my
Vale good morning thank you for taking
my question um do we have any idea how
much traffic would be coming through
this area should this be signed into
I do not have any study numbers on that
but I do not predict that it's going to
be any different than what they have
today um
because the if there's Hillsboro
residents who are driving in this
area one they're doing so
illegally um but they can only take
their utvs down this area and if if
anybody's not familiar with the
difference between a UTV or an ATV I'm
happy to explain
they can only take this UTV down into
this area so it would only be specific
traffic because they are somewhat
landlocked they can't cross Route 31 in
Hillsboro that's a state road and they
don't have authority to cross that road
so it's only the people if you look at
the map on the right side of the page
you'll see that there's Stow Mountain
Road so people who live on Stow Mountain
Road are also on the other end uh
trapped in per se uh by the state road
and the residents within Windsor Road on
that section
around or a second time
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question I'm sorry I'm
still trying to wrap my head around the
authority if the select board decides
not to support this what happens to this
legislation this dies at that point in
time if I get word that they have
decided against it then I will
absolutely make the recommendation that
we kill this bill so far everything has
you representative Taylor thank you for
taking my
question what is the winter maintenance
of the road you mentioned summer twice
but I heard nothing about winter
maintenance the town is responsible for
doing their the plowing of this portion
of the state road so they take care of
any of the plowing and any of the winter
maintenance needs that are associated to
the State Road the summertime the state
is the one that's responsible for doing
any maintenance needs along the
road so wash outs anything that may be
pertaining to that the state takes care
of in the
summertime you know I'd also like to
mention um you know ohvs are usually
less than 1,000 lbs whereas Vehicles you
know 4,000 5,000 more so for the town of
Windsor with they're when they're
dealing with their uh dirt roads and
everything else I think that this this
is a more prudent travel method for them
and helps keep their maintenance costs
the taxes in in the town of Windsor are
$10 per thousand one of the lowest in
the state and I think one of the ways
that they're able to do this is by you
down any other questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you for your
Davis it doesn't there you go good
morning uh
chairman harb uh I grew up as an
equestrian uh so I really enjoyed
hearing your personal uh account of
being a Trail Rider uh I was a
competitive equestrian for 45 years um
and congratulations on your grandson
thank you uh my name is Anne Davis I am
uh a resident of wilmet and I own forest
land in Springfield uh my husband and I
are the uh Northeast region tree farmers
of the year for
2024 our land is
open for public Recreation but not
motorized
Recreation uh during Timber harvests and
our land is actively managed uh we do
find that ATVs are useful in conducting
our forest management work however for
us these machines are tools not
recreational
toys um I do oppose House Bill 113 um
the sponsor did visit uh the
uh House Bill
1188 Commission on Friday I am a member
of that commission representing
Timberland owners and New Hampshire Farm
Bureau um she gave more detail this
morning than she did to our commission
um and we did not really discuss this
bill and part of the commission's
mission is to review and propose
legislation relating to
ATVs uh another part of our mission is
to help mitigate conflicts between uh
ATV and motorized Recreation and other
people using the
trails uh law enforcement as we know is
strapped in New Hampshire
uh with no law enforcement in Windsor uh
if an incident occurs I am not confident
that timely uh addressing the situation
will be
feasible second uh apparently the uh
process is underway to have people have
a hearing and have a Butters be notified
this also was not clear uh in the
present ation that our commission
received on Friday um I feel that anyone
who would be along a roadway that would
have this change in use must be notified
and this is by RSA
requirement and uh so the fact that we
did not really have a chance to discuss
the merits of this bill and did not
receive the detail that this committee
received today I do not support having
you uh approve this uh House Bill 113 at
this time thank you for your time uh
thank you also all of you for your
service on behalf of New Hampshire's
residents any questions does anyone have
a question for the speaker
representative n thank you and thank you
for taking my question is there any
sense of when the commission's going to
make a recommendation on this bill and
other H RV bills um the uh chairman has
not really brought brought it up for uh
we meet every other month uh and we met
on Friday so we will not meet again
until March so that would probably if we
were going to discuss it and
uh support it or not that would probably
be the earliest that we would do so
thank
I can't read your last name but um David
right good morning Mr chair and members
of the committee my name's David rodrig
I'm the assistant commissioner for the
Department of
Transportation um thank you for taking
my testimony the department doesn't take
a position to support or oppose this
bill
but we do have a couple of concerns that
we'd like to bring to the committee's
attention with our read of the way this
this bill is written from our read of
the the bill the law would simply make
these roads open for OHV use without the
public process that is required by
communities when they open class four
five or six roads for OHV use so this
this law is at the end of of that this
chapter and simply opens these roads for
use and it it is certainly our position
that um the law should at the very least
refer to RSA 215
a69 which does require public
notification of the abutters which does
require a public hearing which does
require a request from the select board
and also has a mechanism to um close
these roads to OHV traffic if at any
time in the future um that use is is not
working well the other thing that
section of law requires is signing of
the road so whenever we begin to mix
ohvs with vehicular traffic we think
it's very important for two things one
the ve the vehicular traffic of the
roadway should know to expect ohvs on
the road and the OHV user should also
know where the on road use begins and
ends and this signing would would
provide that so we would recommend two
two changes either this this language be
Rewritten to make clear that in order to
open these class five or class two State
maintained roads the town go through the
process that's explained in RSA 2
a69 that's option number one or option
number two which would require no law is
for the town of Windsor to simply
request of the Department of
Transportation to reclassify this from a
Class 2 State maintained road so to a
class 5 Town maintained road which the
law already offers a process for
communities to open up their class five
roads for OHV use well we think OHV use
is not the end of the world on these
roads they're not particularly high
traffic they're dead end essentially
this would be the the first law that I'm
aware of outside of Coos and Grafton
County that opens up a state maintained
Road for OHV use and we do have concern
about heading down that that path the
law in Coos in Grafton county is very
spe specific to Trail connectors and
connections OHV use in in Village
districts and so forth if we go down the
path of starting to open up our state
maintained roads for OHV use it will
bring a number of complications for us
to deal with from both a safety issue
and a maintenance issue I'd be happy to
take any questions Mr chairman thank you
speaker representative na I promise I
don't always ask this many questions um
if under the suggested changes thank you
for taking my question under the
suggested changes you had if you were to
close the road is that a permanent
closure like if they decide this isn't
working out could they permanently close
it without interference from the
legislature or would this would they
have to come back to change the law
again it's it's my belief that if this
law were to require the town to follow
follow the process of RSA 2115
a69 that process then allows the the the
town to open and close the the road
any other questions of the
testimony in opposition to the
all right now
okay hello good morning thank you my
name is Abby ivanco I live in gorum New
Hampshire where town roads State
highways and several miles of Trail all
AB budding residential neighborhoods are
opened ohvs I'm also a member of the
gorm planning board Secretary of the New
Hampshire rail Trails coalition
and their appointee to the HB 1188 OHV
study Commission of which I am clerk but
today I'm speaking to you as a gorm
resident and taxpayer and a friend of
too many citizens whose right to
Peaceful enjoyment of property has been
destroyed by ohrv Trails misplaced ohrv
Trails um I urge the members of this
commission committee to familiarize
yourselves with the ohrv citing statute
RSA 215a 41 42 43 which dictate all the
criteria that must be met before ohrv
trails are opened on state land um
please itl
hb13 it's not in keeping with the trail
sighting standards spelled out in RSA
2155a 41 42 43 these standards were
written with the intent of producing
protecting New Hampshire residents from
the documented nuisance of ohrv writing
as a Coos resident I can tell you that
the taxpaying homeowners who have The
Misfortune to live along any ohrv
connecting Trail are horribly Disturbed
and begging for these obnoxiously loud
motorized trails to be moved away from
their home and many of these people are
Riders they like riding they just don't
want the nuisance right outside their
doorstep their experience in countless
additional residents in bath Berlin
Claremont coldbrook Columbia Groveton
havil hener Pittsburgh stewarton
Stratford Woodsville just to name a few
demonstrates the conclusions of the
original 2001 HB 717 ATV study committee
were correct these conclusions include
quote emphasis should be on development
of self-contained Trails not linear
Trails new or expanded trails should be
for ATV writing only so conflict issues
will not arise the policy of course find
filtering must remain in place potential
degradation of an area must always be
the Paramount
consideration um there's a summer camp
on One of These Roads does anybody know
has anyone I actually contacted someone
at the summer camp and they had no idea
the road outside their camp where they
have kids every summer was going to be
turn into an ohrv Trail hb13 provides
for no a butter notification for this
dramatic change in use just as the
bureau Trail OHV clubs and towns were
never never notified unsuspecting Coos
residents when their neighborhood roads
and trails were being considered as
connector Trails for ride the wilds and
make no mistake allowing ohvs passed
homes is a drastic change in use from
ordinary traffic of Walkers cyclist
horseback Riders cars trucks and even
motorcycles and tractor trailers ohrv
exhausts are capped at 96 DB which is
twice as loud as a motorcycle
obnoxiously disturbingly damagingly loud
and moreover as any a butter will tell
you ohvs often ride in packs of four or
12 4 12 or more machines which compounds
the disturbance even
further um if you think if you think
this bill has value please send it to
the current ohrv commission for
evaluation our commission membership is
diverse and comprehensive and his task
was studying the complex issues complex
issues of ohrv use in New Hampshire and
proposing legislation to introduce peac
meal legislation out outside of the
commission is to undermine its
work thank you for your
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony in support of the bill Mike
wette
uh good morning uh Mr chairman and
committee members um I signed up the
last minute just to speak um
representative K uh Kum asked me about
uh something about
um HB 1188 the commission to study ohrv
use New Hampshire
and just
to clarify a couple things uh I am the
chair of that
committee and um the committee uh
commission I'm sorry was put together uh
in some legislation and really came
together in
2020 the commission came together in
2022 and there's a quite a
representation of across
the gamut of of Representatives on the
commission uh conservation people uh
aters uh there are four I believe
Representatives uh some members of the
public AB
Butters and um but what it is it's a
study
committee and um and it shows us the
duties in the bill which I have here if
you give me just a couple a minute I'll
just go over the duties uh shall study
current statutes related orvs including
but not limited to RSA 25A and RSA 259
108 our fishing game department the
state police County Sheriffs and
Municipal Police work together to
provide consistency law enforcement and
current laws related rrvs positive and
adverse effects on o reuse in state and
town roads including class five and six
roads the effect of noise dust and
careless Reckless Behavior of riders on
a Butter's Trails where or hrvs are used
educational safety equipment for R ohrv
Riders positive and adverse
effects of ohrb activity upon the state
and local economies and the impact the
impacts of requiring all rental agencies
to stud to install speed regulation
Governors um and all other issues
related to orvs which comes before the
committee they talk about uh uh some of
the itical stuff but there's
no enforcement there's
no um mechanism there for the committee
to uh introduce legislation the
legislators that are on the committee
can but the committee the commission
itself cannot and that's just to clarify
um 1188 the commission to study ohrv in
New
Hampshire is there any questions any
questions for the chair there
representative Sergeant thank you Mr
chairman uh representative so would you
say review of proposed legislation is
within that
scope
absolutely thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you and my final pin
card Claude pigeon Claude if you could
keep it to about five minutes that would
be help F I will speak very quickly
thank
you I'm I
amlin actually I probably don't need but
so my name is Claude pigeon I am from
Berlin New Hampshire I am here
representing myself but I am also a
member of the study committee as a
preface I would like to say uh just
qualification that I do not represent
any one
philosophy to another I have been um a
great uh proponent of motorized Sports
almost all of my life I have been an
off-roader snow machiner pilot um so and
I still love my Harley so the uh only
thing I haven't done I guess is Drive
motorboats I am also a an Enthusiast of
hiking
kaying and nonmotorized activities so I
have my feet in Two Worlds uh so I guess
I'm trying to say that I'm coming to
this um
objectively so my issues with this
particular bill it's rather innocuous as
it's stated as you see it but understand
the nature of this industry one thing
you hate when you're an off-roader is
coming back the same way you went you
always want to be doing Loops that's
just the nature uh nature of uh of the
industry and so yeah right now we have a
node we have a group of people who just
want to access the main Trails seems
rather simple but history has shown that
once you create a connector you don't
have a node anymore you have a node with
an invitation to develop and before too
long there's another node up over here
to the Northwest that says wow you know
6/10 of a mile or 8/10 of a mile has
already been taken out of our 3M
connector this is doable and in a very
short amount of time um you no longer
have a node you have a circuit that's my
first issue my second issue is that the
way these bills are drawn there's no
dead end on it so if two years from now
another club makes a connector and your
traffic goes from 30 units a day to 650
units a day there's no device but by
which you can go back whoa whoa whoa
this is not what we approved it's too
late so the way we write these bills we
do not write a dead end into them and so
your if if your 20 or 30 units A Day
become 600 units a day it's too bad this
is in an area I I look I checked out
Windsor very carefully you have quite a
few youth camps all within a couple
miles and you have a large number of
bnbs so you have an economy basically
that is not necessarily favored uh by
this change in activity those are my
first concerns my second concern is a
little broader not specific to this
topic but um Germain to what was said
previously you have the people in
Windsor who are taking their kids to
school they're going shopping they've
they've become um these these units
these machines have become their second
Vehicles the whole process was
specifically design designed for access
to Trails the idea of using your ATV to
go to aishan to buy your spring flowers
or to go to the AA and do your shopping
is totally totally not what this was
intended to be so what happens now where
you might have somebody coming through
and coming back through six hours later
has grown exponentially you're bringing
the kids to school you're going
groceries you're going to pick up your
your whatever so your traffic has grown
exponentially so instead of having 12 or
15 machines a day you have that
exponential number of four or 500 so the
whole argument of saying that you know
it's our convenience is really contrary
to what the intended initial uh intended
use was um of of these vehicles this
industry and this Hobby and so that
unfortunately is not anything that can
be controlled but yet this is something
you have to keep in mind uh not just
what is presented cuz what is presented
is in fact pretty innocuous but what the
potentials and likelihoods are when you
open up a road and provide permission
for uh for this activity to um you have
to look at the unanticipated results as
well as the intended results and I think
I was well less than my five minutes sir
you did well thank you Mr P I see you
coming back later any questions for Mr
pit
see none thank you for your testimony
you're is there anyone that wishes to
speak that hasn't filled out a pink card
on
hb13 I'll ask one more time anyone else
to speak on
hb13 seeing no one approaching the
speaker table I'll declare this hearing
closed and now that we're after 10:30
I'll move right into the hearing on HB
127 what oh the blue seets thank you
sheets you want them no just tell us how
many voted for and how many against
they'll collect them
them on HP
1113 two three in
favor four oppos okay thank you very
much
FN there's the
cards call the prime sponsor
representative
Willette thank you very much um as I get
started I have two pieces of
um information i' like to pass around
the first one is a letter from um
executive counselor Joseph Kenny in
support of this bill I have a copy for
members and I'm also passing around a
small packet uh that I prepared for the
committee members so they can um kind of
understand what we're trying to talk
about
here so as I start again thank you Mr
chair and thank you committee members
for taking the time to hear this
bill uh House Bill 127 uh seems like a a
very simple Bill all we're trying to do
is make the
trails closing opening
consistent meaning there's on the
Connecticut River Headwaters
land there's a two pieces of Trail total
about 10 and a half miles and it
connects 120 small odd miles Northern
Trails for the town of Pittsburgh and it
connects about 700 miles of Trail South
through cook arrrow all the way down
through
milin Berlin and
gorm every once trails close are are
should say our open until Columbus day
except for that 10 and half
miles and you might ask the question
what's the big deal about 10 half miles
well what happens is we have a very
unique trail system in the North
Country for a couple reasons the first
reason is that it allows you to go to
destination to destination it's really
the only one in the country that does
that that you can get up in the morning
in Pittsburgh and go to Berlin for lunch
or you go to Berlin uh in the afternoon
and go to Pittsburgh for dinner
it's very unique in that
way and not having those two small
sections of Trail open it basically
landlock Pittsburgh so people that are
riding Pittsburgh can't leave the town
but it has a tremendous effect on
colbrook also because cook has
restaurants and amenities but there's a
lot more housing and and um camps and uh
places for for uh tourists stay in
Pittsburgh so they work very very
closely
together but a little bit of background
is that the conect headwaters property
is about 148,000
acres and that sounds like a big number
and it is it's about 228 square miles or
if you look at the other way about half
the size of Sullivan County this one
piece of
property the Kut River Headwater uh
property was created through the state
of New Hampshire and so it would ensure
access to Sportsmen forever there are
easements on the
property and
um so there's Recreation Hunting Fishing
uh there's 10 and a half miles of uh ATV
Trails um snowmobile trails and of
course there's a we're trying to sustain
a logging business uh industry in that
area
also when these easements were made and
this Con heav Waters was put together
Jean she
and Jud Greg were very instrumental in
putting this
together right now the land is owned by
Aurora sustainable lands they own the
property but the state of New Hampshire
owns the roads and in that property
there's well over 200 miles of roads
that are accessible to anyone they're
open um and the Department of Natural
cultural resources oversee those roads
and maintain those roads
so Aurora sustainable land owns the
property but the state of New Hampshire
roads a a few years ago there was an e
economic impact study done and the ATV
business in New Hampshire uh comes out
to about $460 million a year which is
just behind snowmobiling and not far
behind the ski
industry with over 80% of the ATV trails
in Coos
County um we the benefit of most of the
economic
impact and it's a it's a huge thing
we've lost a lot of our manufacturing
base and our tourist business is our
main industry in that part of the
country it sounds like a lot of money
but you have to remember Kos county is
the poorest county in the state of New
Hampshire and one of the poorest
counties in the
country so our typical season is 9 weeks
that 10 and a half miles of Trail we're
talking about right now closes September
30th everybody else in the area closes
Columbus Day anywhere from 8 to 13 days
later all we're asking is just keep it
open that next to 8 to 13 days nothing
else no big changes just keep it open so
that the people from the southern New
England our tourists can have full
system if you look at the economic
impact and break it down it doesn't seem
like a lot but those two extra weekends
for the North Country the economic
impact is about $9 million a
weekend and uh I read a study not too
long ago and they said for every new
tourist dollar that comes in the area
it's spent eight times before it leaves
huge the town of pit the club in
Pittsburgh has over 100 miles of Trail
and if you want to take a look at this
this map here this is what we're talking
about these are all Pittsburgh Trails up
in this area you can see how it comes
through down through cber stewartown
arrol millsfield all the way down to
Burling
gorm so Pittsburgh has 120 miles of
Trail and 110 of it is on private land
only 10 miles is on the Connecticut
River's
Headwaters and again everything else you
see on that map closes Columbus
Day cor has 117 miles of Trail arrol now
has around 160 miles a trail and as a
key to um to the South and so that 10
and half miles by by closing off
Pittsburgh affects all of
us law enforcement in that
area the primary duty is uh by fishing
game the secondary uh is done by the kis
County Sheriff's department fishing game
subcontracts them through the season and
they'll do a lot of the law enforcement
in that
area we're at a hearing uh a while ago
last couple months and fishing game said
that they did not have the manpower to
do law enforcement on that 10 m of Trail
because bird season starts the 30th and
they didn't have the Manpower and then
they came up and said well I think it's
going to be dangerous to have bird
Hunters interacting with
ATVs but you look at that Map There's
800 miles of Trail there that had been
open for many years uh working running
the same time of as bird season and has
never been an issue
so what U the co County delegation has
done uh we put in our budget and made
arrangements with the Coos County
Sheriff's Department that coas County
will do law enforcement on that 10 and a
half miles for that extra 8 to 13 days
so it's no extra cost from the to the
fishing game and for that 10 miles of
that over the last few years
um through climate changes we've all
seen
how um we don't get the snow like we
used to is just had a tremendous effect
on some of the businesses in Pittsburgh
and and throughout the North
Country uh when a business close closes
it just doesn't hurt the people that own
the business it hurts their employees it
hurts the whole North
Country um so anything that we can do to
support these businesses and keep them
going um is good for all of us and and
just a a reminder there's we're talking
about two sections of of of Trail and if
two you can you can see on that one the
one that shows
Clarksville on the uh a to the left that
is coming off Cedar Stream Road which is
a a Town Road in
Pittsburgh and and then where it ends um
that's where it comes off the
um the concut river Headwater land um
that's all we're talking about and those
two Trails uh this one you see a little
360 by the helicopter that's a trail
that connects to C Brook and the other
one connects to connect to C Brook but
also connects to arrol
South and on the third map that is west
of that area and again you can see
that's about a 2 Mile piece and it's not
these are logging roads that are
connecting Trails it's not main roads
it's not traffic roads it's just roads
on the headwaters and they're just
connecting
Trails uh from one to the other and you
can see on this little map here the
amount of trails that you see all those
yellow lines and that's all on private
land all we're talking about is just
that uh that uh two miles or so that are
right there
so I I guess uh that will conclude what
I have but um I also and I can forward
it on to the uh the committee I did
receive a letter this morning from
police chief duie from Pittsburgh um
saying he supports uh this bill 100% And
he does uh a lot of the law enforcement
in the Pittsburgh area to the ATVs and
um absolutely said this is a imperative
for the for the
area and if there's any questions I'd be
them questions for the
speaker representative Sergeant thank
you Mr chair uh representative I was
just quickly looking at the statute that
applies I don't see any other time
periods when a trail is open or closed
in the statute is that is my
understanding correct and if so why
should we do this one in the statute
well that's a very good question thank
you uh the the trail systems
and we can talk about trails and we can
talk about economic stuff but we have
nothing without Cooperative land owners
so I'm a member of the cook Club the
metallic ATB club and we close our
Trails on Columbus Day because of two
two reasons um that's when the hunting
really starts to heat up and that's what
the land owners requested and that's why
uh there's no law that says you have to
close a certain day but up in the North
Country we've taken the uh the the
position that most everyone closes on
Columbus
Day representative NAB thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
has the headwaters advisory Council
weighed in on this legislation they did
and uh they did not support it uh let me
back that up they did not uh
um coming in this legislation this they
had their last meeting that we attended
was an October this was brought up and
they did not support it um and the
advisory committee is uh a lot like the
commission to study ohrv use in New
Hampshire uh we have a a wide range of
people in interest and uh in any
commissioner or anything the the ohrv
business is kind of um can be
polarizing uh and that night there were
more Nays and yays and and so they um
they they did not support it uh but it
just seems like such a minor Common
Sense thing not creating Trails not
adding any money to the budget not doing
anything just closing changing the
closing date by depending on when
Columbus Day is you know 8 to 13 days it
just seems logical to support the
Country um and sorry this is not my
wheelhouse so I'm learning um it's Al my
understanding when it closes that's when
the trail maintenance is done and how
would this extension impact the amount
of time it's uh that's um there is some
done but not generally the way that that
it works um and it's a it's a kind of
a tough uh situation because really the
the season is 16 weeks we start uh a
Memorial Day weekend and we're done uh
Columbus Day so if you go to Columbus
Day it's 18
weeks what happens is in the North
Country a lot of times we don't even
open on Memorial Day weekend because of
snow and it's still too wet and again we
have to protect our land owners and not
you know let anybody on the trails
that's going to destroy destroy their
property so a lot of work goes on during
the summer and there is some trail work
done at the end of the season but it's
what we couldn't get done during the
summer but as a as a rule we don't
schedule Trail work in the fall we want
representative Darby thank you Mr chair
thank you representative for taking my
question as I understand the
conservation easement um that um you
know isn't was put in place as you
mentioned it uh requires Harman of parks
and R to develop a management plan um
and that uh oh use o HRV use is a
secondary use as opposed to hiking and
hunting and things like that that are a
primary use
wouldn't this bill therefore sort of
usurp um the uh conservation easements
um
[Music]
intent I don't I no I don't think so and
I'll tell you why because when the
conservation easement was put in really
the sport of ATV didn't
exist and uh this is a a working
document and as we've all read in the
paper uh dnrc is negotiating with blue s
h excuse me Aurora Land Management uh on
the easement on negotiating how much
logging was going to be and and if you
look in the easement it's pretty black
and white what the amount of Timber
harvesting should be so it's it's as
things evolve uh there's things come up
that change and um so it's a it's a
document anyone else for question
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you very
dncr good morning my name is Craig reny
I'm the chief of the Bureau of trails at
dncr uh thank you chair and committee
for allowing me to testify this morning
um we do have some handouts going around
um I'm glad to hear um chair harb that
it's a friendly committee because I do
have a number of things to cover so
quickly so I guess the first thing to
say is um you know dncr isn't taking a
position on the bill uh we just wanted
to provide some background information
about the Connecticut Lakes Headwater
property and so that's what a lot of the
information in the packet you're going
to see about the property and the
easement and I'm just going to to cover
some some key points in the testimony
this
morning um you know we recognize the
importance of the New Hampshire tourism
economy particularly in Pittsburgh and
but we have to balance that with the
requirements of the Connecticut Lake uh
conservation easement and working with
the Connecticut lak's Headwater citizens
uh committee that was just mentioned so
we have to work with our partners and
stakeholders to figure out those uses um
again background in info it's you know
originally it was 171,000 plus acres in
2001 that was purchase with the Trust
for Public Lands and of that 146,000 was
sold to the forestry company which is
now Aurora and then we received dncr
received 269 miles of roads and 100
acres for the Deer Mountain Campground
expansion also 25,000 Acres went to New
Hampshire fishing game for uh protecting
highly sensitive natural areas and then
the conservation easement was put on the
working Forest okay and then um
part of the management of the
Connecticut Lakes Headwater property it
it's um the organizations our dncr with
our division of forest and lands and
parks and wreck also fishing game
department and then Aurora is at the
table as well as the landowner um it's
also uh and I think it was just
mentioned representative harb it's also
Guided by Connecticut Lakes Headwaters
citizens committee and that's per RSA um
12 a 9B so there's there's specific
criteria in in that statute now and one
of the things I just wanted to point out
is in section B it talks about uh
providing advice to the Department of
Natural cultural resources and the
fishing gain department on the
management of public recreational use of
the Connecticut Lakes Headwaters tract
including uh the seasonal use of the
road system snowmobile trails and their
use and the terms for Access and use of
the track by motorized vehicles um such
advice shall be offered in cooperation
with the private land owner so again
it's kind of a trifecta of management
decisions that occurs with the landowner
and with our sister
agencies um so as mentioned one concern
to consider is the passing of this bill
how does that affect the existing RSA
1289 a uh excuse me b um so it's just
something to consider and then you know
in the conservation easement itself
um you know it requires dncr to develop
in in consultation again with the land
owner and uh Public Access and
recreational use management plan and
that's uh to be consistent with the
purposes of the easement and the
stewardship plans and so the Connecticut
Lake citizens committee U met five times
over the course of 2022 and 23 to
discuss the uh Public Access and
recreational goals for the property and
solicit input um for expanded
recreational uses uh we also released a
survey and and asked for input of of
other expanded uses um on the property
and during that whole process we didn't
receive any requests to extend the at V
season as we went through that all the
meetings were publicly noticed and
notices were sent out um you know about
the committee meetings and whatnot so we
recommended adopting a five-year
management plan that goes from 24 to two
uh 2028 and that was adopted this past
May at the May 10th meeting so again
this was never brought up as we went
through our our you management committee
decisions um and then just finally just
as kind of a quick recap cap that uh
representative olette mentioned uh this
request came to dncr initially to extend
the the ohrv season on the connectic
Lakes property um around Midsummer and
we reached out to the citizens committee
to get input on that as well as fishing
game and we heard several committee
members were opposed fishing game was
opposed as well for some of those law
enforcement reasons uh that fishing game
I think we'll talk about today um and
then uh commissioner Stewart at dncr
issue a letter denying extending That
season to Columbus Day weekend uh the
town and the ATV clubs um did ask at
that point that we reconsider our
decision and it was then brought with a
special meeting in front of the citizens
advisory committee to talk about it and
as representative olette mentioned uh
there was a six to3 vote in opposition
of extending the ohrv season on the
property um so that's just by way of
background that's that's important to
know
um and you know and basically one thing
to not to complicate the discussion but
uh there's a there's a large piece of
private land just off of the property
the Perry stream U tracked and and that
landowner makes their own decisions on
when ATV uh you know trail system is
open and they allowed it to to be
extended to Columbus Day weekend which
is AB buding the Connecticut leges
Headwater property hence the request to
extend it here because they are
connector trails with the private land
um so again uh after reconsideration
dncr commissioner Sarah Stewart um
issued another decision on September
30th to keep it at September 30th and
not extend to Columbus Day weekend and
in her letter she just requested that um
any future um requests to extend the
seion should be in writing to her by
April 1st of this year so that we can
then again bring it to the citizens
committee the Aurora and fishing game
and our partners on the on the eement to
get approval for that um I'm happy to
take any other questions though on this
speaker representative Derby thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question y um if I understood uh what
you just said the um commissioner sorry
Sarah Stewart uh yes she um she said
that if she received a request by April
1st she would um seek input and and
without basically uh within the
guidelines of the conservation easement
um would consider extending the season
yep yep and I think that was stated when
we met with the committee as well uh
again the the timing of you know the
request came last season to extend this
past fall and you know we had a we had
to pull together a special meeting on a
pretty short time period and then again
it got voted down at the committee so it
can come back back up again and but she
just wanted those requests by April 1st
so we can go through the proper channels
and procedure to see if we could extend
it thank you y representative Davis
thank you thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um I'm just
curious do you know Aurora's position on
this um yeah I believe Aurora and I'm
looking to Johanna Lions as our Park
planner and she's also the administrator
of the Connecticut Lakes Headwater
property at um with dncr as well and I
believe their position on that is they
didn't want to extend any additional ATV
mileage or seasons on the trail system
is that is that correct
I for somebody else take it thank you
okay representative NB thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so just to clarify there is a process
for changing the date and this
legislation is sort of an override of
that process is that correct okay y all
right thank
you anyone
else seeing none thank you y thank
iow um my name is Abby Evano from gorm
New Hampshire hopefully you remember me
from half an hour ago um I support the
director of fishing games opposition to
extending the trails
uh on the Connecticut Lake headquarters
um this is there is a public process to
manage these lands and this is an end
run around it um again if we go back to
the trail sighting statutes the intent
is for public interest to uh the intent
is for the public it's in the public
interest to balance the demand for ohrv
Trails on state lands with other state
priorities and non-motorized Recreation
and it must be done in quote cooperation
with the Department a fishing game and
all other custodial State agencies and
there uh so yeah it's in the statute um
it should be noted that fish and game
data shows that ohrv registrations have
dropped for three years in a row since
the covid peak they're now back to their
2018 levels and ohrv registrations have
always been significantly and
consistently lower than hunting and
fishing licenses New Hampshire always
sells more hunting licenses by around
20,000 than ohrv registrations and well
over 100,000 fishing licenses if Coos
County really wants a robust economy we
need to diversify away from
ohvs um there is a fiscal note attach
this bill uh where and it's ongoing um
where does this $10,000 a year go where
where does it come from where does it go
is that the actual cost of law
enforcement for a 10 and a half mile
section of ohrv Trail um given the
condition of New Hampshire coffers and
all our tax uh property taxes going
through the roof is this the best use of
public
money um and uh climate change was
mentioned that it's changing our Seasons
so then it's really in the state's best
interest to reduce our burning of uh
fossil fuels instead of finding ways to
burn more of
it thank you for your
time oh actually I'm sorry I have one
more thing I have friends who live in
Pittsburgh uh I have friends who have
camps up there they've lost the peaceful
right to enjoyment of their property by
having ATVs roaring past their homes
hundreds all day
long questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony Mark Brady in support of the
here thank you Mr chairman um appreciate
the opportunity to come here today um
you know this is a follow-up to I guess
the discussion as you've kind of heard
from last fall on this issue uh what I
would say is this and you know I can
appreciate being in your position I
remember being in the legislature when
Benson was governor and that's when this
was all just started I'm from Jefferson
the county administ rator I've been in
the North Country off and on my whole
life grew up in the tourism business uh
my grandfather started Six Gun City
Norman dub boy who started Santa's
Village they were they were Berlin boys
from the East side and convinced him to
go start six gun so I'm I'm very Akin
and very attune just from that ethos
alone to the tourism industry up north
as you know the north country's two
primary Industries are Timber and their
tourism and between the two of them it's
about $5 billion uh collectively between
the two 3.2 and and 1.6 right around
there and um we've done a very good job
as the state has in general of managing
all the different rights between you
know the conservationist recreational
users uh Property Owners uh Etc but let
me be very clear the
legislature when we went down this road
on the ohrv a lot of us up there we were
not big fans of it but we've learned to
live with it and when with all due
respect when the the nice lady here from
gorum says it all needs to go away there
will be nothing left of the North
country that was part of the issue of
dealing with the Aurora on the
harvesting of the Timber and this
legislation in when you understand it in
context is part of a bigger
understanding by all of a in the North
country and I mean you have the
executive counselor I believe you have
the state senator you have the nine
representatives from all of the North
Country you have the three the three
County commissioners of which
commissioner Gorman here he'll be up
here in a little bit uh you have the
county sheriff we all see it the same
way and when they denied that last fall
and the representative olette just
mentioned what ises it $9 million a
weekend so that's $18
million they took out from these
business owners and you should look at
these business owners when they come up
because that's the market
working again I remember being in the
legislature with with with Governor
Benson and I remember what the North
country was going to get back then if if
if any of you remember this or not you
know Timber the Mills are gone and it
and it's had a profound negative effect
on the North Country we were given two
things by conquered we were given two
prisons prisons and let's do
ohrv and you know what the Ingenuity of
our people they took the
ohrv and they've done an incredible job
with ohrv to the point of New Hampshire
if you look at the study from 2020 uh I
think it's the ninth largest we've gone
into the ninth ninth largest industry
economic prod C in the country that's
unbelievable when you really think about
it cuz think about the size of New
Hampshire you know think about even just
the land area of New Hampshire versus
other parts of the country that are
doing this but again you know we
understand we all understand the
implications of
ohrv Coos County does we understand the
Enforcement issue you'll have the
sheriff that will come up and talk about
that that's a priority for all of our
decision
makers we do look at this very much from
an economic development perspective
effective because we are the poorest
county we're 2% of the population 20% of
the land area Graft in is 16 to 18% of
the land area between those two counties
you have almost half of the state okay
40% is is 2% and 20% of the of the land
area we're generating we have over a
million visitors that come to Coos
County come to Coos County what is the
visited uh what is the number one
visited area of the state actual uh it's
it's Mount Washington now that the old
man is gone it's Mount
Washington now we know rooms and meals
we're generating an incredible amount of
economic activity for you here in
conquer for your communities all over
this state we would argue that we're not
getting we're not getting back our fair
share but that's not what this
discussion is about today we've got
other things going on that we're going
to start to explore that because the
North Country at the end of the day is
not just your our North Country it's
your North Country too we are the
identity of the state we're generating
economic activity and it is absurd it is
ludicrous and it's one of the nastiest
things I've ever seen by some
bureaucrats and conquered to say you
know what we're not going to give you
two weekends we're not going to give you
basically 5 days for all intents and
purposes five days and somehow because
those five days is going to make all
hell break loose and this can't be done
that's bull that that that's that's
bull and we operate from the county
perspective we operate two nursing homes
we're the only only county in the state
that has two nursing homes one in Berlin
one in West stewartown we have our
Correctional Facility as you know the
state downshifts costs to the counties
it's not a fun place to be to run a
county and it's sure not a fun place to
be to run a rural County this is not
Hillsboro OR Rockingham
Etc and that that $18 million that would
have been generated that's real money to
our residents that's real money to our
tax base that gives them the ability to
pay their taxes Etc which are
skyrocketing you go to Pittsburgh which
has a a population of what is it 850 to
a th000 let's say it's a to keep it
easily a thousand you can go up there on
a weekend you can have 4500 5,000 people
they actually just had their first good
weekend for this this this winter was
just this past weekend because we
finally got some snow all the way up
North and the climate change has
impacted certainly the importance of
ohrv because you can't rely on the snow
machines the way you used to I grew up
on snow machines going up into kill
Kenny the end of our property you you
can't rely on it anymore the way you did
that's why they did come to the table to
ask for it to have it open last year
because we have been beaten up we
haven't had good winners at all and I
don't understand why why you here in
conquer would object to that it it it
just it does
not it's to me it's not fair this is
good responsible public policy with
representative wette and our
representatives are proposing
here and we're asking you to
please
please let this be open and we've been
forced down this road and I want to say
something about
dncr you know dncr with all due respect
to dncr the way they run their shop in
the
easement they forced Coos
County the smallest and the poorest
county in this state we had to go find
our own
attorneys to have them interpret the
easement that Shaheen and Greg spent 30
million dollar of all of our money with
both Federal monies and state monies for
that
easement to try to get them to enforce
the easement they have not done their
fiduciary on that
easement
and so again this is an important issue
to us I would urge you as well when we
start talking about this easement to
going and look at CO's submission on on
the Aurora component of the stewardship
plan right now there's no harvesting of
log of of logging going up it's very
minimal we've gone from 40 to 30 down to
we we at 10 even this year this is
important to us opening these Trails is
about economic activity and doing it in
the right way and we urge you to please
please pass this
legislation I'd like to remind all the
speakers that we try not to impute
anything on any of the other departments
or any other speakers so if you could
just watch all the speakers watch what
you say about anyone whether they're a
prior witness or a state representative
or a department representative we try to
maintain decorum here in this friendly
committee understood and I think that's
what my fellow wanted to say do we have
any questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you very much
oh we had
[Music]
one then
don't thank you for taking thank you um
I'm a little nervous to ask a question
after just being spoken to in that
manner um if there is a process that
needs to be followed to open these
followed there's a process
and I would argue that the process isn't
working okay and uh because there's a
hard date of April 1 so they lose I
would say that's they had good reasons
to want to ask for that okay and and I
don't know why you would sit there and
say with all due respect
representative um I certainly wouldn't
oh well they missed that April 1st so
that's it so why should be treated
differently I'm not I don't I don't
think that's the issue at all okay
personally and and I will tell you this
as well what what I think from our
perspective is that um excuse me thank
you I I'm I have your answer thank you
very
much any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you Mr pigeon you're back
again thank you but my concerns have
been eloquently addressed by previous
speakers so I will uh gladly
uh not be redundant and uh uh wave my
opportunity to speak again thank you Mr
pigeon we appreciate that because we
have quite a few other speakers here
it's lined up with pink cards in support
of the bill Ray
Gorman County Commissioner District
number
three thank you folks who give me the
time to speak today here and I believe I
can offer two three different angles on
this situation that we have going on in
the moment I am part of the headwaters
committee as well
and first of all it it this is an
economic
issue as well as you'll hear the uses of
non-motorized but this this issue
shouldn't be completely that way because
the bird Hunters primarily are the group
in there at that time they tend to not
come as heavy as many of them early in
the season because of the leaves all
right Etc I I'm an avid Bird Hunter I
have bred Britney American Britney bird
dogs for 40 years I have competed
nationally Canada won multiple
championships in American Britney Hall
of Fame and I don't want to be dragging
right now but I'm just want to tell you
that to get to that level where I did
was I need to train my dogs a minimum of
three times a week an hour per dog okay
run two at a time and I know where the
birds are I know we're the best places
out of train my friends do as well and
one of the things I will say is that the
area that the trails that we're asking
about to affect the bird
Hunters it's it's not in my opinion
that's significant compared to Scotts
bogs East Inland and we're talking a a
very large area here and the trails that
we're talking about is a small area 10
miles versus 200 miles of Roads Etc it
it really should be the importance of
just the the area we want is important
so I believe there's no reason why the
bird hunters and the other people I I
feel the bird Hunters what they do is
they drive up a road they see a pull off
and they go with their truck okay if
they have dogs they unload their dogs
and out they go two three guys they're
Walkers it's the same thing all right
they're not on the roads I mean there's
the old road Hunters yes but they're not
in the same areas as the ATV people and
even if they are they're off the trail
they're in the woods the guns that they
are using are Shotguns with low pellets
okay they're not out there with double
odd Buck they're not out there with
slugs okay so some of this needs to
balance and and I think it's a big part
of this
today that's my part there I think
there's no reason why that cannot all
work there's no reason that Bird Hunter
should be just fine that should do well
economically I live in cber I'm a
selectman in COK as well I've been
involved with the HRV some of the things
that you talked about your previous
hearings our our community we did the
public hearings we have roads open
we''ve you had to work with it
enforcement so on and so forth and is
working and is a tremendous boost to our
community economically it has brought in
several people that have bought houses
it makes a difference snowmobiles and
ohvs for the North country is a huge
thing Miss
and the ripple effect of this last
weekend was the first decent weekend of
snow snow in Pittsburgh all the trails
are open Pittsburgh was very busy and
cook was very busy our restaurants were
full all weekend our Motel was full and
the ohvs I think even have more of a
ripple effect because the Berlin gorm
traffic loves to come to Pittsburgh they
go there have lunch and head back so it
affects all of our area but we have and
in the last few days I went around in
the past week I've been around to the
businesses I've been around I've U to
the Selman I have a statement here from
the selectman as well I'll have passed
out to you folks I should have given
that to you immediately of their support
the majority of the board supports that
these Trails stay open till Columbus Day
weekend it's important to understand
that it affects everybody up there it
affects I'll say it affects you guys
with rooms and meals so on and so
forth and lots of people have spoken on
that and I'm going to keep stressing
that being part of the advisory
committee there's a document that was
written there's copies of the public
hearings okay and it was clear in those
documents and what those folks did back
then the Fred Kings all those folks
economics was a big part of this all
right they wanted to protect the timber
industry the forest industry okay they
wanted to make the document also
flexible in in that document it talks
about motorized Sports okay so it's
before the
OHV times okay and the economics of the
area they were very very specific about
how important they knew what this
tractor land how special it was and how
much it meant to the North Country okay
to the county all right and and I think
Mr Brady made a very good we have ohvs
snowmobiles that's one of our big things
we have the prisons in my area okay
we've lost so much industry it it's just
you know my brother lost his job in a
paper mill my sister lost her job in a
in a Furniture Factory so the whole area
I mean it it it needs this these folks
when they came this summer to the public
hearing they had just come off from two
bad Winters all right and not
necessarily a good summer because we had
so much damage from the floods those
100e floods that are now becoming 5year
floods to Trails to roads the winters
without snow okay they needed some help
all right at the public hearing that
night for that committee all right it
was quite obvious the people in that
room okay a large majority I'm willing
to say 80 to 90% were absolutely in
favor
all right of keeping those trails open
for 10 more
days it's it's it needs to be seriously
considered and uh we appreciate your
help with it I'm going to give you my
statements that I have from the uh
Pittsburgh select board who I spoke with
last night um I think Mr Brady and
everybody else made it very clear that
the County Commissioners are totally
behind us for our whole County you know
right right through Senate Joe Kenny and
definitely all of our reps so I hope
that we do have some influence on this
folks thank
you oh whoops any
questions representative Davis thank
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my
question uh commissioner do you see any
downside to this
legislation could you say that one more
time do do you see any downside to this
legislation anything that's oh
absolutely not absolutely not I mean I
think that this no reason we're talking
10 days to start with we're talking a
town that's been specifically singled
out okay out of a whole system all right
I mean Co County the state let gave us
the ability to open our roads open our
Trails recognizing what it would do for
us all right and then we close them for
for what for 10 days why it's in the
residents there want it open so it's
it's AR we need to keep that open for
our area and to through the business
that we have and so on and so forth and
uh and we there is in that agreement
that was made there's a lot in there
about Economic Development if any of you
guys ever have time go to the website
connect Headwaters and read some of the
old history spend an hour or two reading
that stuff you'll you'll be surprised I
think it's a great document I think it's
very well written and you can see what
those folks were trying to do and um you
know they wanted to keep the logging
industry strong and they want to keep
the tourist those were the two big
things wildlife of course thank you any
other questions for the speaker
representative Darby thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question and
thanks for um you know articulately
describing uh the challenges and I'm
wondering as a member of the committee
um and um if you think that the process
that was described by um dncr and uh
advocated for by the commissioner could
work if um
if there is a way to extend it using the
public hearing process it's when it
comes to hrvs it's it seems to be
difficult sir um I asked earlier when
the the committee was working on the um
trails and all the the document that was
just signed it I asked about because we
needed a we were looking for a connector
Trail I think it was three miles long
between the kak ATV Club and the
Pittsburgh club and at that time there
was significant resistance from Aurora
they were not allowing any more trails
to be opened it was it but I was told at
that time that I could bring it back up
all right and that we did have the
ability I mean we we you know but I
think we need help from you folks here
to show that this process needs to
happen in an objective way all right and
I an objective okay not just anti this
or anti-
that I hope that answers your
question any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimon and I'll give the handouts
Mr chairman thank you again for the
ability to uh speak on House Bill
127 um several people have already
spoken and raised some points that I had
in my prepared testimony however um I'd
like to make a couple notes uh we mark
and I have a conservation easement on uh
our property that's next to the guile
State Forest um that is held by another
entity as is the Connecticut Lakes uh is
the easement is held by the state of New
Hampshire um we are still the land
owners and we still have the right to uh
have a say in the management of the
property um there are uh quite a few
restrictions that are contained in the
easement uh but it is a working Forest
uh conservation easement um we've
developed uh 10 miles of Trails um at a
significant cost to us uh for for that
so I would I would suggest that the
committee
weigh the uh rights of the landowner um
part of me sees this as a property
rights issue and
uh representative ulette read part of
the uh ohrv 1188 commission's uh
objectives um but there is one other
that he did not refer to so I would like
um number five the report the commission
shall report its finding ings and
recommend proposed legislation to the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
the president of the Senate the house
clerk the Senate clerk the governor and
the State Library honor before November
1st of each year so part of our mission
is to weigh in on legislation we did
just learn about this particular uh bill
but we did not discuss it and we did not
make a decision one way or another on it
so thank you again for your time and
thank you for your service to the people
of New Hampshire any questions any
questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you again for
your
testimony I have five cards all in
support so I'd simply ask you try not to
repeat what somebody else says I know
all your testimony is important uh but
we appreciate it if you could take that
into consideration the first one in
support captain Michael Eastman New
Eastman Mr chairman and members of the
committee I apologize to excite everyone
behind me but uh the uh Fishing Game
Commission is actually in uh opposition
of this um bill so then you checked the
apologize my other uh card that's in
there for the next bill is would be of
support
then thank you all uh for having here
today I uh I am here at the beest of the
uh namp Fishing Game Commission um they
had uh had all met and taken a vote to
oppose um this uh this proposal or this
bill um certainly uh and this uh comes
from the uh when we first went in front
of the committee and were asked about
our stance on uh opening uh this section
of the headwaters property it um it was
that uh the reason for the closure at
this time is because uh small game
season our
Hunters um for grous and and such open
on October 1st uh so therefore the
caveat of opening up this property was
to uh close it so that it was open to
primarily to our
Hunters um certainly director simc and
uh the commission and myself understand
you know how important ohrv Commerce
Commerce just to Kos County and what the
ohvs bring uh to the North Country um
but this section of um of property the
headwaters property uh is and was
designated for
Sportsman um and for their uh use of
that property now certainly
um that's our primary goal here is that
we um we look at the rights and the
Privileges of the hunters and and how
they can better be successful now
certainly I've worked this is my 23rd
years as a conservation officer I've
checked hunters in that area and and
ohvs obviously um and what I've seen is
that this is really a a destination um
there are articles written about
Pittsburgh and uh small game hunting um
there are uh I've checked hunters from
as far as uh Wisconsin and
Minnesota and uh with them they bring
obviously their dollars and they bring
their their animals with them um and
certainly some of those dogs that they
that they run um would cost as much as a
a UTV um so that's really one of our
concerns is that there would be a a
potential adverse um interaction between
those Hunters that have come here and
possibly travel from afar um and then
also the other part of that is that as
we've heard testimony that uh n fishing
game is the uh primary uh law
enforcement uh agency that covers the
enforcement of ohvs and hunters and
fishermen on that property now
understand uh we do uh certainly give
ohrv monies uh to Coos County Sheriff's
Department to patrol and they Patrol you
know throughout their County um the only
issue is that and and I will say that
there is a lot of law enforcement
especially recently in Pittsburgh with
Northern borders stone garden um patrols
that are going on up there actively and
their primary goal is to to do those
Northern borders duties um you know for
illegal entries and drugs and what the
issue is is not necessarily the amount
of enforcement that's in the are area
it's what that enforcement is doing so
for
instance the law enforcement up there
does not cover accidents that occur on
the Trails um and those accidents um you
know they will go and they certainly
will um take information um and give us
that information um but that does not
alleviate my officers from having to sit
down on a Monday and fill out an
accident report and everything else that
goes along with an accident um so we
really are the primary ones that are
taking care of that um and and uh so uh
really you know I'm here for the hunters
uh for the other Sportsmen that that
benefit from this uh property like I
said uh director simc commission we
understand Commerce we are there for the
ohrv community um we are there when
there when new stores open up in in
gorum uh we're there for the Pittsburgh
old home day for or Jericho Fest or
whatever they call it these days um
riverfire we're there really to support
the oy community and unfortunately this
is just one uh section of the support
that we cannot give to that Community
um that's really the end of my
testimony any questions representative
NAD thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question a previous speaker
mentioned the numbers of hunting and
fishing licenses versus o Riders does
fish game have any sense of that or any
tracking of those
numbers unfortunately I didn't bring
that here today um certainly um when uh
Abby Evan Co U did spoke about that data
certainly um you know it it's yes we do
sell more hunting fishing licenses than
um ohrv and through Co ohrv the people
were looking for something to do atving
UTV that was a big thing that they did
number really spiked up and then they're
starting to come down to where they were
you know preco so follow up follow up
would you be able to supply us with
those numbers of course all right thank
you very
much representative
G thank you for taking my question I I
may not have heard correctly I I think
someone may have said that these uh
Hunters go to another area a swampy area
or someplace rather than this particular
particular area that's is from here is
that correct or what certainly uh
they're I mean they go to Pittsburgh in
general so that doesn't exclude one east
east Inlet I mean there's there's a tons
of places they could
go this is one section that's open that
is there specifically for sportsmen um
that is you know State Property um and
uh so yes there's other places they can
go they can go throughout Coos County um
but um like I said this section was
specifically set aside for sportsmen or
women of the
state representative
Davis thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr Eastman for taking my question I I
guess I'm I'm a little unclear why this
10 miles of Trail differentiates from
the rest of the trail system up there
and as uh as commissioner Gorman said
Bird Season doesn't really get hit hard
until the leaves drop I I'm just curious
what would hurt that for that uh two
weeks of of being open to help out the
economic development of that
region thank you for that
question
um you know certainly
uh it's only 10 miles it's only two
weeks uh we understand that and and uh
but I'm sorry can you say that question
one more time well I I don't I'm not
clear as the difference uh the maps that
representative wette brought show
hundreds of miles of trails and it's
just this one little island what what is
the difference it I'm just curious why
is that uh should be held different than
the rest of the state thank you for
repeating that I lost my train of
thought um I think the opening and
closing dates of ohrv use throughout the
state is probably one of the most
confusing things that we have going out
there
um I think that uh you know one part of
the State closes at this time the other
start part closes at this time some
Rockingham Trail is open year round this
Trail's open year round you know I think
yes there are other portions that are
open so but this once again is a is a is
a section that was set up and and where
Pittsburgh is a destination place to go
um for grous hunting now certainly I
know people come to the Pittsburgh
October 1st and throughout and and once
again atving yes it may start a little
bit later in Pittsburgh um but certainly
there's at least a 90 days for which it
is open and now you have bird Hunters
that have um really technically three
weeks um from October 1 until moose
season starts the third third week of
October and then you're into youth deer
season and then you're you're into a
regular muzzle loader season so really
this a very short window for which small
game for the price that they pay for the
price they pay to come to this area uh
has to to hunt those areas do I probably
one of the best ways to shoot a grous is
to wait until the snow on the ground and
and drive down a road and they're
they're sitting on a branch on the side
of any Logging Road in Pittsburgh um but
once again that's not when the main
Hunters come and run their dogs and and
come to the Pittsburgh area for my
experience yeah can I have a follow up
follow
up uh I understand that that the trails
open and close at different times but
wouldn't that make sense to put this in
align with the rest of the state
confusing I would agree would make it in
line I would not agree that this is the
time frame for which I if if it were up
to me I think that and and looking at
hunters and fishermen as as the primary
individuals to benefit from the
disclosure it would be that the state
would close down on on September
30th okay thank
you
representative R thank you Mr chair uh
thank you C Captain correct um is there
anything uh just a point of
clarification is there anything
jurisdictionally prohibiting uh other
law enforcement agencies from performing
um the tasks in a law enforcement sense
that fishing game would provide in the
North country country or do you guys
have a mutual Aid agreement up there
where uh local police County Police they
can all work kind of cooperatively and
if I'm taking your testimony from
earlier right if there is an accident or
something your office would still be
involved in that based off the um gather
evidence Gathering from the local um
authorities is that
correct so the agreement that I spoke
about earlier is our ohrv PD uh ohrv PD
grants so portions of the OHV fund go
towards it's $30 $40,000 goes towards
enforcement um of ohvs any Police
Department can put in for that and they
have jurisdiction within their
municipality Coos County Sheriff's
Department puts in for that regularly
they get actually the the largest amount
of that fund to do enforcement um which
really generally is around
$10,000 um and they have and they have
the authority as well as State Police
Pittsburgh Police Department
um they have authority to enforce the
the rules within their jurisdiction and
they can cover the accidents that occur
well representative Derby representative
ghoul can you shut off your mic please
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question just briefly what's the
speed limit on these roads that you're
talking about for the
ATVs everything's about 25 miles hour
unless otherwise marked
followup and followup and um uh based on
your um on your U you know enforcement
exceeded I can tell you this the the
cause for ohrv a and snowmobile a is the
biggest contributing factor is excessive
speed and um basically inexperience so
yes that's probably one of the biggest
tickets that we write as as for
excessive
speed anyone new
representative thank you Mr chairman uh
Captain are these roads closed like to
ohvs at that time you know like
September 30th are all motorized
vehicles uh denied access or just the
ohvs
unfortunately I can't answer that
question because in my mind I can I've
definitely been across Cedar Stream Road
which is closed at times um it's
probably a better question for uh for
chief renie um I can't speak to that
section okay thank you because he the
previous speaker mentioned how he you
can hunters can bring their trucks in
with the B you know their dogs and stuff
so I wasn't sure what if they had access
or
not that's what's confusing to me
there certainly are sections where you
can operate into those areas there are
other sections that are gated off um I
can't speak to why that is or or why it
isn't um but um you know certainly there
are times when they are open when they
are closed okay thank
you representative Davis yes thank thank
you uh so I'm I'm still unclear if
there's 228 square miles of small game
hunting why this 10 miles of trails
which is so crucial to the economic
development of that area would would
much all they can speak to is that they
the majority of the land that that o
operate on is private property um
outside of Rockingham Trail know Jericho
State Park things like that so it's
really up to the landowner when they
choose to um open or Clos Trails um this
section even though it it does the 10
and 1 half miles um it is under the um
Advisory Group and it was designated for
the sportsmen and women um you for use
of those those
individuals um and so therefore um like
like I said my my commission feels that
uh that it's important for those those
hunters and fishermen have their their
say and and that they and that's why
this section has always been closed
because for those hunters and
fishermen thank you any other questions
for the
captain seeing none thank you Captain
much I have Keith robur the uh Coos
County High sheriff and um if you can
keep it less than your 10 minutes would
be
appreciated I'll try to give it real
quick uh
Keith robach I just got elected as high
Sheriff of Coos County I have been
working for Coos County for 27 years
before being Sheriff I've gone through
five sheriffs and when the captain
brings up about accidents our prior
sheriffs fishing games expertise oh hrvs
snowm Beals Hunting Fishing it wasn't
ours so they always were under the
standing where let's let them do their
expertise so we don't mess up their
accident reports is the new sheriff in
town I'm going to change that and I'm
hoping with fishing game we can go
through send some of our guys for
training with them on
accidents major accidents I mean fatals
that's their expertise but our guys will
be there and they are going to cover
accidents this year it is great they do
give us funding through the Grant I
think we got a little under 10,000 last
year um the county puts a substantial
amount in so the county will give us
20,000 pit Patrol fishing game so we got
$330,000
in the summertime we put three guys out
designated just for ohb to help these
guys because when it first started it
was like the wild west up there and
without all the agencies coming together
it would have been a cluster I think
we've done a great job our rentals were
a lot of our issues um we've hammered
down on rental companies and they have
been great to work with when we write
their guys tickets that they rent to
they're very glad they actually tell
them if you're speeding you're going to
get a ticket um jurisdiction wise we
have jurisdiction throughout the whole
state can make an arrest right here in
conquer whether that Pittsburgh Nashua
we stay in Coos County you know but we
do have the ability our guys do arrest
um we do a lot of trolls I think last
year our guys rolled about 238 Summoners
and about 680 warnings just on
ohbs and we've been seeing a lot of
increase where people stay in gorm and
that's their starting point destination
Pittsburgh
so and our guys sometimes stop them on
their way up and stop them on their way
back so they go to Pittsburgh stay
overnight in a hotel or cabin or
whatever and then on Sunday they drive
back and come back to gorm and come back
home so we are going to be out we are
going to I'm going to make sure I have
at least three guys if it does get open
for those 10 days or whenever the trail
is open designated up there I was on the
phone with Chief duie from Pittsburgh
and he supports it and his guys are
going to do the same thing as
well thank you Sheriff any other
sheriff representative Sergeant uh thank
you Mr chairman just Sheriff uh a quick
question so I I didn't hear you say
either way I'm assuming that you're in
support of this legislation yes we we're
in support of it we're going to support
it we're going to patrol
it what do you think the economic cost
to you with the extra co uh patrols will
be
the economic cost your department for
the extra patrols luckily for us we use
a lot of we call them part-time
full-time people so these are retired
full-time guys that work part-time for
us and they have so many hours they can
work so we actually don't have to pay
time and a half for those we will
because our full-time guys will be out
there doing it as well but I mean on a
weekend you know they're
getting 30 bucks an hour and they're
putting 10 20 hours in you know so you
take three guys it costs money but it
cost money to make money and I think
it's very important for Coos and for the
taxpayers and Co-op that provide you
know Pittsburgh we don't want them on an
island
so thank you any other questions for the
sheriff seeing none thank you sheriff
for
youron I have a Kai for someone who says
no opposition so since I had three in
favor still left I'll have David
Aurora takes no position Mr
kozie thank you Mr chairman uh my name
is David czy with Prospect Hill
strategies here in town uh on behalf of
Aurora sustainable lands Aurora is the
the land owner of the CT Lakes
Headwaters Forest uh did was I the
company didn't have uh and had a plan to
speak today but I did just want to uh
make a slight correction to the
company's position on this legislation
our uh Partners at dncr they did
correctly note that uh the company is
very cool to the expansion of trails on
the property but on the issue of
extending the season the company has no
position and so I just wanted to make
that uh
make that
distinction thank you any
questions the
speaker seeing none thank you very much
thank you Mr
Rober hello my name is coren Rober I'm
the owner of bay Rock adventures in
Pittsburgh New Hampshire um so I'm I'm
the face of what you're talking about um
my business is motorized Sports started
out with a TV rentals in front of my
house used to live down in the North
Conway area and owned a restaurant
wanted to get to an area that was more
remote and had more Trail access Mo both
snowmobiling and
atving um our business started in
2013 we started out with 10
ATVs we now have 50 and 50 snow machines
which may sound like an enormous impact
on the area in regard to noise and more
people but the reality of it is is that
we have 15 employees in an area that has
800 people that live there so 15
employees that are full-time that's a
big deal when you lose Seasons or pots
of a season for instance last winter and
this is relative to ohrv because they're
all connected you we may have what seems
like year round but the reality is we
have 6 months of operation and then need
to fill 6 months of payments with bills
and employment pay so last year our
season was to begin December 15th which
is when the trails open for the winter
we open January
11th we still have payments we still
have employees typically we run through
to the end of March possibly April 15th
we closed March
1st to put that in dollar figures for
you in a small business that equates to
$175,000 of lost
income often times we don't open on
Memorial Day for ohrv because of
$75,000 when you close 30 days or sorry
13 days you close on the 30th of
September
the adjoining Town colbrook stays open
so we're literally talking about a
10-mile Trail if you do the math that's
7.7 acres of
land that's what we're talking about to
NE connect one system to the next so
Pittsburgh's gas stations retail
locations rental locations lodging
establishments food
they all lose and I'll put another
dollar to that because we have the
ability actually to take our rental
business and move it to our Campground
that is in
stewartown it's not ideal you try moving
machines to another location for
anywhere from 8 to 13
days do the math lots of trips lots of
gas
a lot of money when we shut down our
retail store shuts down for that period
of time that equates to about
$150,000 that's a lot of money for a
small business when what we're talking
about is for you to just say this
doesn't make an ounce of
sense what's going on here we're not
looking at who can do what we've been
asked to do reports when we have
accidents by fishing games because they
can't get there we do our
part I collect registrations and sell
the decals $60,000 last month we sent to
the fishing
gang a thousand of it granted the
seasons change a thousand of it was for
license the rest were for snowmobile
registrations so we typically collect
about
$275,000 worth of
registrations in a year
we don't make money on that we lose
money on that so what we have to do is
we have to make money where we can make
money so we're asking you to give us
next year it's 13
days we would close on a Tuesday but we
want two
weekends you try paying
payroll for 11 weeks when you don't have
that income anymore it's not a joke it's
a big
deal we do have other things that we can
collect off of so we start Ecom but the
reality is this this Pittsburgh
Hampshire this is what we are living off
of my husband was in the logging
industry since he was 16 he had to get
out because it's
collapsing it got out three years ago
what's our business our business is bar
Rock Adventures living off of the land
living off of The Economic Opportunity
within the area so don't shut it down
just consider there's a real face and
it's not just the rental agents we work
with the authorities we work with land
owners we work with the town we own 700
Acres those Hunters are all over our
properties they don't stop hunting
anywhere else but on this seven
acres like that makes no sense granted
they may be processes and granted we may
be asking for a process that doesn't
seem as it it aligns with what you think
should happen but does that make any
sense either when this can happen and it
matters does anybody have any questions
for
me thank you thank you for taking my
question thank you for being here today
um is there any sort of Chamber of
Commerce or Business Association in your
town that has taken a stance on this do
you have any stance of that I'm
currently not involved in the Chamber of
Commerce but I was for over seven years
okay and The Stance is that economically
is the greatest impact on the area at
that point in which I was involved I did
a short study with the real estate
agents in the area and then again
because we own several hundred acres and
my husband has been in logging for a
long time we also do real estate devel
development on a small on a residential
piece 80% of all properties that were
sold were sold because they were
connected to Trail systems both
snowmobile and ATV that's a
reality that's yeah representor
Bridal thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question today sure uh
thir 2013 is when you said you started
yes that's a long time have you found
that over um over over a decade worth of
being in business up there when you lose
a holiday weekend like Memorial Day
Weekend the amount of and and that's due
to weather correct to have an arbitrary
date of September 30th um where you
could have another holiday weekend 8 13
days later that that additional holiday
would make up for a loss of a holiday
weekend at the beginning of the season
so like the the amount of money that is
brought in by a holiday weekend is worth
more than just having an arbitrary date
of the end of the month yes so let me
get that straight you're asking me if we
lose a one end do we do I think that the
extension of that season would help
offset that loss absolutely one of the
things that happens is Memorial Day
weekend can often be impacted by the
snow level we don't have that typically
in the middle at at the beginning of
October to the middle of October so yes
anything that we can get we need and if
you do remember correctly the past two
seasons for o rving we' had several
closedowns due to um rain that was
impacting the trail systems um so some
people one of which was one of my
lodging establishment that you could not
access on the trails so yes if we can
gain 10 or 13 days on the other end
absolutely it matters you're
welcome any other questions for the
speak seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you in favor of the bill Darren Darren
jock
um most of my points have been brought
out here but I would like to just touch
on a couple of things that are that are
very
important um obviously October 1st is
the same all the way through the state
as far as hunting goes
and for 10 miles I that's that can't
even be a
consideration for what
we're this we we brought this to be this
last summer we we have a new land owner
the the Perry stream property was is
about 8,000 acres is our primary trail
system that we're talking about
connecting to um they came to us this
year and asked if we could keep it open
through Columbus Day so we met with our
town Selectmen and they unanimously
agreed this spring to go on board with
this so we brought this decisions to
Trails Bureau uh June 1st we requested
this so
um when this this April 1 date that
they've talked about just came to be
this fall so we will be pursuing this as
well um again in April if we have to uh
it's it's a shame it's got to come to
legislation the state of New Hampshire
owns those roads we spent $40 million is
to get the rights to those roads um and
we should be able to to make this a very
simple process um I'm on the board of
directors for the great Northwoods
Riders and I also own a business in town
and this would be huge for for all of us
so I thank you for your time uh you have
any
questions any questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you thank you
appreciate the handout our last card uh
Dawn Gorman in
support and for those in the audience I
the next bill I have like six cards and
I don't have any for the last bill um so
uh in discussion we're just going to
keep going so if you're there um this is
the last one on this bill we're just
going to continue with the next hearing
after that thank you yeah good morning
uh Mr chairman and thank you very much
uh good morning Mr Vice chair and Mr
clerk also
and uh if I deviate from the bill here
for half a second I want to congratulate
all the people who ran for and a newly
elected to the state legislature
congratulations well done um Mr chairman
I've been listening to the testimony
here uh for quite a while and uh I think
what I am going to speak about is a
golden
opportunity to develop the North
Country resources Recreation
development this would probably be inim
study but why are we confining ourselves
to a 10mile trail when we should be
expanding the entire North Country Coos
County anything north of Lake wiip
why do we not have worldclass
snowmobile
races why do we not have dog sled races
going from Berlin to
Montreal why do we not have a train that
comes from Montreal to Berlin and why
would you go to Berlin because you got a
manufactures Ste mobiles the Berlin
bomber if you will what we want to do in
my opinion Mr chairman we want to expand
our thinking there's no reason why the
fish and game department should be in
here opposing this bill there's no
reason why people who say we need
conservation should be opposing this
bill there's no reason for anybody to be
opposing this bill what we are looking
for is economic development of
everything
the bird Hunter who goes bird hunting is
very happy to spend 50 bucks down at the
diner that afternoon the economy of the
entire North Country will develop and
expand we can include all of the people
who have concerns that have spoken here
today to put something together with the
thought of we are going to make the
North country
one of the shining places in the in the
United States to go if you think of Lake
Tahoe what do you think of
skiing the best skiing in in the
Rockies when you think of Berlin what do
you think of trees logging let's expand
that let's get some great great
development going on in the north
county I I I just can Envision with the
effort a major effort being put in and
by this committee I might
add this committee is
specifically what are we looking at
resources Recreation
development this committee could be the
most exciting Committee in the entire
legislature uh barrowing Finance of
course Mr Gorman I appreciate your
passion I can see it from this far away
but can you keep your comments to this
bill uh I I thought I was Mr chairman in
addressing the people who were opposing
this bill I don't see why they're
opposing if we include them into a
development and specifically to answer
your question Mr chairman if this bill
was to put on inm
study we could take those two instead of
killing it as we usually do instead of
that we could add
develop with the fishing game with the
conservation people develop a worldclass
organization up here in the North
Country so I may be drifting off the
specific of the bill but I see this
great opportunity for this bill so
that's pretty much what I have to say um
and I'm very glad that I came today to
listen to the testimony here and if
we're including everybody um I think
that's a great way to go and this is not
a Democrat Republican bill this is a
people of the North Country development
Bill if you're getting on a lift ticket
I don't say uh are you a democrat or a
republican you want the family day pass
that's what I'm interested the economy
of the area so I may have drifted I
apologize for that Mr chairman but I
think I got my point across oh we thank
you for your testimony any questions of
the
speaker seeing none thank you very much
is there anyone else who didn't fill out
a pink card that wants to talk about
hb17
FN yeah you need to fill a pink card out
but you can take the seat and tell us if
against no you won should speak so we
can move on on hi my name is St
wi hi my name is Steven Wilkey I
represent New Hampshire off highway
vehicle association we're the
association of the 23 clubs um I was not
going to speak on this bill but I'll
make it quick it's very hard to compare
hunting and fishing licenses which are
for an individual person to machine
registrations a lot of our machines now
carry two four or six people so
comparing those numbers are apples to
oranges
and I would I would caution against that
um Nova does support this in that it
would universalize the closing date
above Route
26 and it make it very clear that above
Route 26 it closes at Columbus Day Above
The Notches closes uh October 31 and it
would then very universalize the closing
dates up there at that is it any
questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you if you
could just fill in the pink card and
pass it
up on the blue
Sergeant seven in
favor five opposed one
neutral thank
you so having no one approaching the
speaker's table and and having heard all
those that wish to speak I hereby
declare the hearing on House Bill 127 FM
closed we'll move immediately on to uh
House Bill
174 and calling up the prime sponsor uh
again thank you uh Mr chair and thank
you committee members I'll be very brief
HB 174 basically changes the definition
of an
ORV uh taking the weight which is
currently of uh 2100 lb to 3500
lb the reason to do that is um
basically their orvs are getting a
little more fancy little more sophis
icated there's some out there now with
air conditioning and heaters and
electric windows and they've gotten a
little bit heavier so they're a little
bit over the current weight
limit the second thing that is important
this is going to give the ability for
the manufacturers to allow and produce
electric
ATVs so if someone is very you know
environmentally conscious it's going to
allow them to do it the batteries are
heavy we need the extra weight in the
definition um this um this law I mean
this bill uh I brought it in uh at the
request of the New Hampshire off highway
vehicle association
Nova um but as far as ohbs and
dimensions there's a limit in the state
of New Hampshire depending on the trail
system of no more than 65 Ines in
certain areas other areas no more than
50 Ines this doesn't change anything
nothing is changing except the
um we discussed this quickly for a few
minutes uh a couple months ago at the um
commission to study uh ohrv in New
Hampshire and um the director or I
should say the the uh exact title is but
the head of Bureau Trails said he felt
that the change in weight would not have
significant wear on the
Trails um and I think that
um you're going to have a little
testimony after that shows that the
manufacturers and the tire manufacturers
have um Incorporated new designs and
Technologies to reduce uh Trail
wear but again as I had mentioned
earlier no matter what kind of trail
system you have the land owners are the
key to have a trail system without
Cooperative land owners you don't have
anything clubs have um access to what we
call Grant nade through the bureau
trails and that's uh money that goes
grants that go to the clubs to help
maintain trails and like my club again
up in the in cook we have some uh trails
that we use on logging
roads and getting that um Grant aid
helps us to maintain those roads when
required and just for information you
know we put out in 2024 over 100 dump
truck loads of gravel on our Trails as
maintenance not building
um so I think that um our land owners if
they the ATVs have much less PSI
footprint compared to cars trucks uh any
other vehicle uh I don't think that the
extra th000 pounds is going to be
significant uh to tr Trail damage and um
I would ask the land owners to please uh
uh communicate with the local clubs and
to make sure that uh they stay happy and
local clubs will work with them to
maintained questions I see on my right
uh representative
NAB thank you for taking my question
thank you um how is this enforced what
is the enforcement mechanism for the
weights really there isn't okay uh
fishing game of course is Primary Law
Enforcement but I don't think they're
equipped to do U any kind of weighing um
and and like I said Nova has uh proposed
this and it was just to be upfront and
uh to be keep everybody legal so that
there isn't a problem you know we're not
trying to hide anything behind the
curtain uh where things are getting
heavier or or we want to support the
manufacturers that that want to bring
out uh battery battery powered and
utvs
Bridal thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question you have to excuse my
ignorance I'm not ohrv Enthusiast um
when it comes to registration of these
vehicles uh I know certain vehicles that
are on our roadways get um higher fees
for a higher weight due to the impact on
the roads is there any sort of uh
proposed higher fee that is attached to
this or is that something that was
considered is that not considered at all
in in uh when when this was created part
from your testimony from your experience
everybody um in the ohrv world whether
it's a side by side or or or a
four-wheeler they pay the same same
registration um is it um an idea yes is
it out of the question I mean it's got
to come to legislature and we can we can
discuss it but uh at this time
everything everybody pays an eval
fee any other questions representative
yes thank you chairman uh representative
is this build to compensate for the
weight of the batteries or for the size
of the machine to answer your question
precisely it's for the weight of the
batteries the size of the machines uh
has is not a consideration in this we
don't want to change the size of
machines we do not um we want to keep
the widths the same so because a lot of
trails are gated so we we want to have
ohvs and side by side on on Gates uh on
Trails but we don't want jeeps we don't
want trucks we don't want other vehicles
so a lot of them are gated at 65 Ines so
the that's why the state law is maximum
65 Ines and some of the trails in
Rockingham County they're only or and I
think up in towards Sullivan County are
only 50 in but it's totally for weight
not for Dimension yeah okay thank you
representative
ghoul our battery are operated ohvs
quiet versus the other
kind
extremely any other
Taylor for gasoline powered ATVs at this
3500 lb weight what would be the uh
approximate average horsepower and
maximum speed of that
unit when we uh and I had mentioned
earlier some of the fancier ones coming
through with the air conditioning and
heat and that sort of thing um most of
the ones the manufacturers are on that
platform it's about uh 100 horsepower
and um most of
those I'm going to guess top speed is
maybe 70 M an hour but as a reminder the
25 representative diary thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
representative pette um I was reading
last night that um and I think it was
mentioned earlier that in many cases 90%
of the trails are private um what do the
uh land owners think about the increased
uh weight and are there would this
require renegotiation of the um
agreements with the land owners for this
increased
weight the clubs uh can't speak for the
whole state but I know the clubs up
north um really have a an honest and
working relationship with the um with
the land owners of course uh I know for
my cobber club we have 120 miles of
trail and I think we have 108 land
the they will if this passes they will
be notified but um according to the
studies I've seen and I think that my
friend from Nova will bring us some
statistics that as far as uh ground
disturbance um it's insignificant
else uh thank you Mr chairman Mr
representative as a prime sponsor I'm
assuming that you're familiar with the
the language in here uh I'm hearing two
main purposes one is for Ev batteries
but the language is not limited to 3500
pounds for an EV ohrv right it's just
for all ohvs so I'm assuming that it's I
I do like the batteries obviously but
I'm assuming it's also for the the
fancier ohvs like you said and I'll
explain a part of it
myself I have a standard off
theot uh OHV side by side it's a Polaris
General it's not very fast it's kind of
comfortable
um and after I bought it I put I put a
winch on it and I put a windshield and a
winch wiper and I put a heater and uh I
put um a spare tire carrier on the back
and I put a spare tire on it and I carry
a tool box I carry a recovery box which
got some straps and winches you know
stuff if I get stuck and and a jack and
I carry a cooler I'm over 2100 lb
so
um I'm I have nothing fancy but legally
I'm
overweight and of course I'm not the
world anyone new representative
Bridal thank you Mr speaker thank you
for the followup um in in that regard is
there anybody
um I'll cut right to the chase do some
of the law enforcement vehicles that are
out there with all their extra equipment
added equipment or say first other First
Responders Fire EMS some of their um
setups that they have to operate in the
North Country would they be similarly
equipped uh and therefore overweight
currently in your
opinion I I know I can tell you what I
know uh the city of Berlin has their own
ohvs that they uh patrolling the trails
they are overweight the Coos County
Sheriff's Department on their ohvs are
overweight um fishing game I don't know
I haven't seen them out on the trails to
to know exactly what they're riding but
yeah some of the law enforcement guys
are definitely overweight by Teddy's uh
definition representative Ryan thank you
for taking my question um can you
explain unladen dry weight to me I'm not
familiar with that
term it says 35,000 pounds unladen dry
weight in the right so
um when uh the
manufacturers build a unit they weigh it
and said this is the weight and unladen
dry weight mean that there's no oil in
it no gas no fluids of any kind no
operator Bare Bones that's what it
built anyone else for a
question s yes representative Darby
So reading the bill um there are you
know 215
a434 state starts out by saying that
ohvs can um uh cannot be over a th000
pounds on state owned Trails except for
and then there's a couple of exceptions
Coos County another area that I'm not
familiar with and Jericho Mountain which
you took me on last year or earlier so I
appreciate that um how how many trails
are we actually talking about here uh
that would um that are 35,000 3500
pounds versus the
Thousand I can speak
um for the North Country which is what I
know from gorm North and Northern
Grafton County which is from maybe uh
Lisbon North um that those are the
trails we're talking about it's probably
a little over th000 miles um when you
get to the rocking inam County Trails I
believe those are only 50 in so that
would you'd never have anything 50 in
wide that would be that heavy and I
think that some around the Claremont
area same thing that the trails a little
bit narrower so it wouldn't have any
County seeing no one else thank you for
your testimony well I want to thank the
um the chair and the committee for uh
tolerating me today and it's been a
pleasure
ianco sorry it's good afternoon
now um I'm Abby Veno from gorum New
Hampshire uh this bill changes the
allowed weight of utvs on certain State
lands to increase by
75% while HP 174 directly applies only
to State Property which is about 200 mil
of Trail it will impact every landowner
whose property connects with State
Trails um in North Stratford alone 150
land owners allow ohrv Trails on their
property HB 174 has no Provisions for
any notification or in input from land
owners or towns about this weight crease
because ATV trails also go over town
roads class 5 class
six um and uh meanwhile both land owners
and ohrv clubs alike have expressed
concerned at the degraded state of the
trails the uh inability of the bureau
Trails despite their best efforts to
maintain them properly and the
increasing severity of storms so a
drastic increase in allowed weight won't
that speed up erosion and where will the
money come to repair more damaged Trails
we've all heard about the uh Titan
budget that New Hampshire is
facing um a recurring theme of the peace
meal ohrv legislation is that the
property owners most impacted by the
changes in law are not notified or
considered or asked for their opinion on
the issue if you truly want to reduce
the complaints around ohrv Recreation
then it's time to stop the peacemeal
approach let the ohrv study commission
continue its work we're supposed to uh
submit a report and legislative proposal
by November 1st of every year and we
have our final report is due November
1st
2026 uh we our our commission is diverse
we're big um and let us do our work and
propose a workable bipartisan leg
legislation bring up some of the good
questions that have been raised here so
please itl this bill or send it to the
study commission for evaluation thank
you questions for the speaker
seeing none thank you
Abby speaking in support of the bill
Stephen I can't read the end of your
Wilkins hi thank you uh for hearing us
um as I said earlier my name is Steven
Wilkey I represent New Hampshire off
highway vehicle association who is 23
uh one of each need to go to everybody
there's multiple letters of support
there um so we represent 23 clubs ohrv
clubs in New Hampshire uh and about
15,000 members um we pro pro promoted
this legislation because the original
UTV definition which is different than
the ohrv definition in New Hampshire was
created over 15 years ago when they were
truly utilitarian vehicles uh mule or
Gator John Deere Gator Kawasaki Mule
made for the Ranch in Texas over the
last 15 years our machines have evolved
into severe recreational usage and along
with that has come four seat vehicles
enclosed C tabs heat and AC and when
they started adding the heat and AC they
started going over the 2,000 pound dry
weight limit and um there have been
these vehicles out on the trails for the
last four or five years the gas powered
ones as we studied um I I also do sit on
the 1188 study commission and I am also
president of the Sullivan County ATV
Club in Claremont so
um as we we studied this these vehicles
are getting out there because there is
no um enforcement of the weight limit um
New Hampshire has done a really good job
over the years of defining our o hrvs we
have a separate definition for trail
bikes which are ride on Two Wheel
Vehicles we have a a definition for ATVs
which is up to 1,000 and 50 in wide we
have a definition of utvs which has been
originally 62 in and 2,000 lb in 2014
the 62 in went to 65 in so we've already
adjusted this definition um and and now
we are at the point where we need to
adjust it again um interesting also is
jeeps and trucks are considered Ohr vs
when operated off from a public way so
on our landowner permission forms there
are four boxes trail bikes ATVs utvs and
jeeps and trucks so we have had actually
land owners checking off jeeps and
trucks on their own property so those
are getting out on some properties um
also when a municipality opens their
class six roads or class five roads um
they often open them to ohvs which don't
actually have a width or weight limit
because conventional Motor Vehicles are
on those roads also the class six roads
that we often are considered Trails we
have um uh tractor trailers on them
because the logging um and very heavy
equipment my local Club suvin County ATV
Club we just put a bridge on a Class 6
Road it was a 60,000 pound Bridge we uh
as an organization and Bureau Trails
have encouraged clubs when they update
Bridges to make them so that you can put
heavy equipment across the bridge to
take the and maintain the trails so when
we put a 60,000 lb bridge in on a Class
6 Road um I met with the logger this
summer he's like H in the future when
you do a bridge make sure it's 120,000
lbs so we can get full logging trucks
across there
so the the logging industry it will do
uh you know a lot more weight than this
1500 lb weight raise uh that we're
looking at and and a lot of talk has
been about the electric machines coming
down the road and while they have just
started to get to the public um the
manufacturers are working on detuning
the electric so they don't have as much
impact the other letters that were um
passed around with you um we have one
letter from Roa which is the
recreational Highway Vehicle Association
of the whole country many other states
are aligning their UTV definition to
3500 PBS and uh there's at least four
other states that are doing that
currently so that letter will show that
support uh we also have a letter of
support from Polaris Polaris is the
number one manufacturer of op High
vehicles and um they have gone to
extensive uh educ uh engineering to
engineer these machines to have a
lighter footprint on the ground they
have employed the uh tire manufacturers
to to develop better off highway vehicle
tires which are low pressure wider
better tread compounds and better tread
patterns
for on and off pavement um so these uh
letters of support and the chart
explaining the off highway vehicle tires
versus a conventional Auto uh Tire um
shows how less impactful just 1,500 lb
more will be so um I will keep it short
and appreciate you listening to my
testimony and and we answer any
questions any
Vale thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I just wondered if
you could Supply us with a vehicle um
with a picture so that we would be able
to tell what the difference in size is
and what each of these vehicles look
like that will we be voting on so in
other words if we're at 2,000 lb now
what is the size of that vehicle and if
we're at 3500 lb then what is the size
of that
vehicle size will not change our maximum
width is 65 in that is enforced by
weight width limiting devices on state
land um so the actual physical
dimensions of the vehicle will not get
any larger with this definition change
only the weight of the vehicle so I we
can gather some pictures and we can
email them off to the to committee so
differences representative NAB thank you
Mr chair um I know you don't repres
thank you for taking my question I know
you don't represent Roba but they
mentioned 80 Ines as a width in their
letter is that a future goal no not at
all we we will never go wider than 65
because as soon as you get to 68 in now
you're getting into some of the Jeeps
and trucks and we don't want them on
these designated Trails the 65 in is
been an accepted width um for the
manufacturers uh they do make a 50in
side by side uh UTV which goes on the
state trails in Central and Southern
parts and you know those uh state laws
that uh talk about 50 in uh other than
grafting Coos is really only on state
owned land the private land owners and
municipalities have the choice to allow
larger machines so at solivan County we
have um about 45 miles that allow um uh
utvs and only the 9 Mile Sugar River
Rail Trail which is state owned is 50 in
uh and we have about 20 mil of class six
roads which jeeps and trucks are out
there with the High Press tires and in
all honesty the Jeeps and trucks do the
most damage versus any of our machines
thank
you representative
Baldwin thank you Mr chair thank you for
question as I understand
it one of the benefits of increasing the
poundage would be to accommodate
electric batteries is that correct that
benefits we're talking about the North
country and people in the North Country
have a hard time plugging in an electric
vehicle because there's nowhere to plug
them in in the North
country where would these um electric
vehicles be plugged in where would you
get the power there's no infrastructure
for that
so thank you for your question um part
of uh the 1188 study commission is to
study electric charging stations at
Trail heads um but we often like in
Jericho we've got five big wooden
turbines up there making a bunch of uh
Power uh they could be plugged in there
and Out West what they have done is
Standalone solar uh battery packs where
people can plug in out in the middle of
wilderness um uh New Hampshire is kind
of a doughnut hole for electric uh all
the states around us have um increased
their electric capabilities and charging
capabilities and I think I just saw that
New Hampshire is finally going to get on
board and try to get more uh charging
stations um but the the the future is is
in front of us and um you know while not
everyone is going to be into electric
those are going to be uh built as as
time goes on um rivan which is a
electric vehicle um made by GM and I
can't remember who their other partner
is but they have actually got many uh
charging stations out in the middle of
the desert out west and um so that they
can take the electric vehicles from one
place to the other for you know
thousands of miles so uh you know we
it's just starting to get developed and
solution so Mr wiy I have a question
sure do these vehicles because I also
like a fellow representative I don't
have one of these vehicles do they have
a tag in it like my car that says how
much the dry weight is in the vehicle uh
no they don't but every manufacturer
when they do um it comes out on their
spec sheet so every vehicle out there
you can look right up on the internet
see what the dry weight is and know that
that is um our uh Community has been
trying to self- police this for uh the
last seven years as long as I've been
involved with this um as the machines
have gotten heavier you know one group
of our Riders says oh that's too too
heavy for our trails and um when you
know re reality is these are the the
machines that people want um and and I
will put it that uh five of our land
owners um that I know who have Trails on
their property already have these
overweight machines and they are out
there as land owners themselves thank
you any other questions from Mr wiy
representative
veale thank you Mr chair um it got my
curiosity when you mentioned a tag um
would it be possible to get like one of
those tags that goes in the window that
says what the features are of the
vehicle
the 3500 lb vehicle um just like when
you buy an automobile isn't there
something that says
what's the machine is made of I'm not
sure the the manufacturers are willing
or even have ever thought about that uh
yeah thank you for taking my
question representative Darby thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question
um we you talked about the size but how
about the engine sizes between the
difference are they are there larger
engines to uh you know to get these 3500
lb uh o up to 70 M an hour and if the
engines are larger are the um noise at
25 miles an hour
comparable so the most of the side by
sides um are between 700 CC's and 1,000
CC's um the the th000 CC will do 70 um
if you had a long straightway and you
you built up speed but um our our speed
limit on the state owned trails are 25
uh private trails that are not marked
are are 35 but a lot of our Trails on
private land you can't get a machine to
go faster than 20 or 15 miles an hour um
it's really on the roads that people are
Trails so the the sound difference um
Polaris has also um been working on um
re uh tuning their engines through the C
CPUs of computers to Dune um I will tell
of a story out in Sedona cal um uh
Arizona there was a rental agency and
when you leave the rental agency and go
out on the the road the the rentals
would always step on the gas and it
would be very loud so Polaris went in
there retuned that engine so it was
quieter and it wasn't so bothersome to
the the neighbors and now they are
carrying that onto a lot of these
machines um when a lot of the sound
complaints stem way back to two stroke
machines dirt bikes and sport quads
those are two stroke racing machines and
often times when people would get those
the first thing they would do is change
the exhaust which is where our our hard
exhaust laws came about where no
modified exhaust that modifies it louder
than stock um most of these side by
sides and even the ATVs now are all
fourstroke much quieter and the
manufacturers recognize the noise
any other
questions seeing none thank you Mr wi
for your T thank you very much for
listening and asking the questions in
Davis thank thank you again Mr chairman
my name still is an Davis uh and I am
Ino opposition to House Bill
174 um other speakers have pointed to a
couple of the reasons why I oppose this
bill so I will not go down that rabbit
hole however um one I have two
significant
concerns uh these vehicles would be
allowed
on trails in coas County the amusic
recreational trail from haal to
Bethlehem the Warren recreational trail
in Warren in Crafton County and Jericho
Mountain State Park so these are
state-owned Trails but as previous
speakers have acknowledged most of these
trails are
connected through private
landowner uh
agreements um so my question and concern
is these private land owners who
comprise
80% or more of the trail system are they
being advised of this potential change
and uh if they are what kind of
notification will they be given um and I
did a little research last night and
just thinking you know 3500 lb that's a
75% increase in these vehicles and um I
thank Mr wilky for helping to educate me
about uh you know the current weights
and so on and so forth about these
machines um he's so knowledgeable and a
great resource on our
commission uh but you know the curb
weight of a 2023 Toyota Tacoma is 3900
lb so one of these 3500 lb machines with
you know a couple of people and the
cooler and the toolkit and all the rest
so I'm concerned about the weight and
what it will do to Trails not only in
the states owned by the state but also
for private land owners
um and again uh we the commission is
aware of this bill but we did not really
discuss it in depth and as I mentioned
before that is one of our um
uh purposes to propose and vet uh
legislation which I think would help
answer in the future some of the
questions that you you know this this is
a great team you've asked wonderful
questions you pay attention um and it's
a privilege to have an opportunity to
speak before this committee um but I
think we could help save you some time
in the future on ATV legislation if we
got a chance to uh vet it first and
finally just to speak on behalf of the
commission um we are a talented Bunch um
I represent landowners so I do but I use
an ATV so I'm not completely anti ATV
but I
will always speak on behalf of land
owners um but Captain Eastman Chief
renie uh representative ulette um and
various other members we are a talented
diverse team um and I hope in the future
we will have more of a chance to vet
these uh pieces of legislation just so
that it's we can provide you with a
better document to work with thanks
again it's been a privilege as always to
speak before this committee any
questions any
questions seeing none thank you for your
Eastman I think I changed your C you're
for this
bill we are in support I olizee for that
confusion I will endeavor to do better
want to change without your approval
that's thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee uh The Fishing Game
Commission is in support uh of this uh
of this bill uh the reason being is that
uh Nova and uh came to us and about this
bill and and I too at first looked at it
and said well increase in weight what
what does that mean um and then I looked
at really what the gross weight of a
Jeep Wrangler is off the lot and it's
about 5,300 um pounds and this would not
bring that that you know the 3500 would
not bring it to that level wouldn't
allow Jeeps or anything else um the
other part of it is as well is that as
you increase uh weight you're going you
know we're restricted to that 65 in in
width and manufacturers just can't make
a machine that's uh that's heavier and
not make it wider so really we are
protected by that width um going forward
and um so therefore that's why we would
we would support it thank you any
questions for the
cap seeing none thank you C thanks so
much Jason
so good I guess good afternoon at this
point for the for the record my name is
Jason stock I'm the executive director
of the New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association and coming around is
testimony from Robert Johnson he's with
the New Hampshire Farm Bureau Federation
and we both are submitting testimon he's
submitting testimony and has signed on
through the web portal in opposition to
this bill and I am here to testify in
opposition to this
bill um and uh wanted to First give you
a little bit of uh background on who we
are um our
organization represents Timberland
owners in the state's Forest products
industry our Members Own or manage over
a million acres of land in the state of
New
Hampshire and
um you know a lot of that land is open
to Recreation um whether it's it's
pedestrian use or in in many instances
Trail use you heard earlier today that
um that I think the number was 80% of
the trails in the state um are on
private land so we're a big stakeholder
in ohrv use and Trail use across the
state and we we have a good relationship
with the state agencies that regulate
and and monitor this um and and for the
with the local clubs as well there's a a
good Cooperative relationship in in
almost all
instances um for a forest land owner you
you
own 100 acres even 50 acres the value of
that Timber is dictated in large part by
access if I can't get to my wood cut it
and get it to Market its value is is
greatly diminished so what so anything
that affects or has the potential to
affect my ability to access that Timber
and I'm talking about roads skid Trails
log Landings if anything impacts that it
it actually has a dollar effect on my
bottom line um if I have a piece of land
that's on a class six road on the
backside of a class six road that has
been that has been weathered and used
and is impassible for my logging truck
for me to access my Timber and get that
to Market I have to put a significant
investment into that road and that
excuse me affects my bottom
line um when I brought this bill before
our policy committee I just want you to
know that's kind of the context that we
look at these bills bills like this the
land owners and and two of them are
large land owners from Coos County
they're private land owners they own
hundreds of thousands of acres and their
their eyes kind of bugged out and they
said you know right now oh and they
support ohrv use they support it on
their on their property they have
easements or right of ways um which are
updated annually or every five years
with New Hampshire Trails Bureau they
support the sport they recognize it's an
important economic engine but they also
recognize that's a there's a financial
there's a financial downside if that
road gets degraded if that road really
starts to fall apart and recognize these
are not highly engineered roads um in
some instances we're talking about skid
trails that have over time been kind of
developed and graded and and cultivated
into a trail so we're not talking about
an interstate or a a road where you have
lifts of of gravel and and uh fabric uh
erosion fabric underneath it many times
these are skid Trails or Hall Roads that
have been kind of developed over time
and so they they looked at the bill and
they said you know right now our roads
are taking a beating as it is um we have
instances and it's and it gone are the
days I should say of the bad apples we
could always point to well there was
that bad apple he went out or she went
out they should have been out there in
in March when the ground was wet they
said that's yeah you get some of that
but the volume of traffic on some of
these roads has gotten so large that
roads um one of the L one of the
Foresters said he said you know my my
roads are starting to look like creek
beds or stream beds because the fines as
these machines go over it you get dust
and the dust are your fines and that's
what knits your Stones together you get
those dust that blow off and they said
you know we manage it we recognize these
are important but these are some of the
impacts that we see and particularly on
private land that's a cost to me as a
land owner to maintain that road and
maintain my access to do the management
the timber
harvesting and and so that's that's the
point those were some of the comments
that I got from
them although this is specific to State
state-owned Property
or state-owned Trails there are some
there are some concerns you heard
already today about the connection
connecting Trails Perry stream was
mentioned a couple
times um so there are connectors that
aren't state-owned we also heard couple
that with the fact that we heard that
this isn't really enforced or
enforceable um absence say a sticker as
representative Veil had suggested it's
very difficult to enforce this um
fishing game doesn't carry around a set
of scales like our friends at the
department of safety when they stop our
logging trucks and weigh them along the
side of the road they don't carry scales
along so you have you have a situation
where I could be riding along at on a
state state-owned Trail I need to I want
to go to point B I'm going to cross over
you're out in the woods without a lot of
signage it's very many times very
difficult to know that you have you have
wandered on to private property it's a
it's an accessible Trail and so we heard
earlier that with the Connecticut Lakes
you know this issue of confusion about
dates we've got a trail here with a date
closing date and another Trail let's
take that and apply it to weight limits
I've got a trail here that says 2100 lbs
um oh now I've got a trail that says I
can go up to 3500 lbs you get the same
confusion concerns and same confusion
issues that you could see with that with
that closing date that we you you folks
on I guess the the other the other piece
is you know this there's the spillover
piece with respect to State ownership um
you know you talk to a real estate
attorney and I know there are a few
attorneys probably in the room what is
ownership if I have a right of way
across my property or an easement across
my property that the state of New
Hampshire holds it we we believe that's
a ownership interest and therefore does
that entitle that trail across private
property is that trail now eligible for
a 3500 pound weight limit um and I want
to point out that we're talking about
weights and we're throwing around
numbers here you know 3500 3500 lbs is
an unladen weight we've all that's where
that's we're Now setting kind of the
basement here as we've heard earlier
today you add on all the goodies and and
forget battery packs but you start
adding on some of the other goodies
3,500 lbs can certainly become a lot
more so that's that's something else we
want you to to contemplate Rob Johnson
does a good job at discussing the quote
un what is unladen depending on which
section of law or which state you look
at unladen can mean different things um
and so that's really that's not really
defined what is
unladen um and lastly I would I would
argue just I would give a plug for the
house bill 1180 88 subcommittee in the
fact that this it would really have been
good to have this vetted a little more
thoroughly before that committee for
those who have testified or excuse me
have been been in this committee for
years we can all record call the
ohrv kind of turmoil and part of the
solution was let's create a sub commit
let's create this study committee so
that we can Hammer these issues out
beforehand try to get some modom of
consensus on it before we throw it into
the the committee and say here you go
here's my idea and now everyone
including myself comes out of the
woodwork and says whoa whoa wait wait a
minute did you think about this did you
think about that it would have been much
more efficient to have had this some of
these discussions and and some of these
comments made in that in the context of
that study commission um you folks do
get you do get paid for your service to
the state some would argue not enough um
and you know let's make your job easier
let's use that study commission for what
it was intended for um and so with that
I will I will conclude my my testimony
I'm happy to answer any question and
again um oh the only other thing real
quick when we look at weights um there's
been a lot of talk about comparing ohvs
to SUVs pickup trucks Tacomas pick your
pick your favorite
vehicle I think the thing that the ball
that we've got to keep our eye on is
we're not talking about comparing 3500
lbs to my Toyota Tacoma we're talking
about 3500 lb to what is existing law
2000 so to say oh this is all right
because it's not as heavy or as bad as
that I don't think that's the
appropriate way to think about this it
was mentioned earlier we're talking
about a 75% increase and to increase a
weight limit just because there isn't an
easy way to com to ensure compliance is
probably not the best reason to increase
a weight limit let's work on getting
these let's get a handle on the enforce
M piece and then figure out what's
really going on before we start
increasing weight limits so that we can
say all right now we feel good we're in
compliance because it's
3500b let's we set we set a weight limit
at 2100 for a reason let's let's enforce
that this time I will conclude my
comments and I'd be happy to answer any
questions and thank you for your
patience any
questions one question yes sir Mr than
you Mr chairman
um I'm reading down here the your
definition of
uh dry un Laden
weight specifically some say States in
case of electric vehicles the battery is
not included now see I'm trying to
reason why they want to increase the
weight limits now my thought process was
okay well they want electric vehicles
and the batteries weigh so much
I go that's a great idea because you
know it's going to decrease the sound
because everybody's complaining you know
about the noise but now you're saying
that you know it's not going to include
the battery weight or is is there some
written something written on to confirm
that uh sure if if I may chairman um to
respond to that question and this was
something that Rob Johnson had had dug
up with the Farm Bureau this is you're
you're really getting at the nub of the
issue here is or the Crux of it is that
there is not a universal definition and
I will talk to Rob and we will he can
provide you where it is it is in one
definition does not include batteries um
there are other def definitions that
include you know X you know di Minimus
amounts of petroleum and so again it's
this kind of murky area what is UN
ladened and now to kind of put a law
enforcement person in the seat of trying
to enforce something that's not clearly
defined just creates conflict and
problems I'll talk to Rob and we'll get
he can he can dig that
up follow up follow
up okay can you answer
me this I don't
know um I'll try
objectively why did did they i' say they
seeking this weight
increase I haven't heard any reasoning
why on
this otherwise because I said the size
isn't getting
bigger um so why is there why are they
seeking this weight limit increase when
everything seems to be hunky dory now I
don't that's where I really I'm really
you know it's the batteries okay that's
a great idea but doesn't seem to be that
so so I I sat in I sat through the
testimony you heard before I heard two
things I heard one is the battery piece
if you get electric you kind of enter
this other Universe of weight when it
comes because of the batteries in
electric but the second piece is is one
of compliance there's concern that you
have an O A UTV today that's maybe 2100
lb you start adding on all the
goodies you're out of compliance with
that with that weight limit so let's
increase the weight limit and now my TV
with the goodies is now legal that's the
that's the testimony that I heard today
is one of compliance with existing
internal combustion two is the electric
and
batteries well then let's just increase
it to Laden
weight no no anyway thank
you other questions for Mr
star one
more thank you Mr chair um
so if I understand you uh correctly you
said that there are existing easements
um that um members of your Association
hold uh are held on properties that your
Members
Own um it sounds like they don't include
weight limits in those easements and so
um it's it seems like they're I'm trying
to understand what you said are are you
do you believe that this is sort of um
an intentional taking of by adding on uh
more
weight so thank you for your question so
the
easements so I'm I'm a land owner I have
20,000 Acres I have a trail that crosses
me that's an important trail that the
New Hampshire Trails Bureau wants to
ensure remains open they approach me and
say will you grant us an easement to use
that strip of land for an ohrv Trail I
haven't seen the easements um I don't
know to what level of specificity they
get into regarding weight limits my my
assumption and this is my assumption is
that they probably just mirror existing
law why wouldn't they um but so what I'm
saying is in in my point was if I have
an easement whether it's granted or sold
the state has a real estate interest on
that strip of land now they have a legal
interest there is a document a legal
document that says State of New
Hampshire you have a legal interest on
this strip of land for ohrv use when I
go back to the bill that we're dis
discussing today it talks about State
ownership and state owned trails and so
the question that our kind of real
estate attorney types are asking is okay
if that that's the case Jericho Mountain
Park that's easy State owns that fee
ownership they own that Lock Stock and
Barrel but what about an easement that
they own they that's a strip of land on
you know a piece of property they have
an ownership interest in it does this
apply to that or was that the intention
and that's the concern that our our our
members had is they said look this is
although I don't have state doesn't own
the
property um they may have they may be
able to claim an ownership interest on
this or let's say a a local um ohrv
Enthusiast or Club says whoa whoa wait a
minute I want to drive my 3500 lound
vehicle across that piece of private
land where the state has an easement on
it and state you have an ownership
interest your this bill says if it's
state-owned I'm going to claim my
interest in driving my 3500 lb vehicle
across it whether that's a taking or not
you know I guess you know this is this
would go into effect these easements get
updated once every one to five years um
presumably they would mirror that they
would reference law and that would be
perhaps a point of discussion but my
point is is that this we talk about
where kind of the boundaries that this
applies it's not just Jericho and the
the other areas that we talk about there
are there is a potential implication for
private land where the state does have
easement representative Sergeant thank
you Mr chairman could you walk me
through that because I'm confused and I
think I might be reading this wrong then
uh the language of the statute I thought
it was um on state-owned Trails the 50
Ines th000 pounds applies except for
Jericho
Mountain I thought it was just limited
to
Jericho no no let me let me let me let
statute it's Jericho
Mountain it also talks about um there's
also this definition also applies to
trails in Coos County state owned trails
in Coos County um I don't have a copy of
the statute itself so it's my my read of
it and I I could be wrong but it was
also a a application of
this on Jericho Mountain as well or
excuse me um state-owned trails in Coos
County and then the other I think there
was reference to to amonk and there were
some other trails that were referenced
where there's state state
ownership again nevertheless the the
concern the spillover concern is I
someone comes up for the weekend rides
their 3500 pound ohrv on Jericho
mountain and says all right Saturday
that was a lot of fun where do you want
to go today kids let's go for a
ride north um up towards uh you know up
up towards arrol on these state state
Trails they have a right of way State
trail again without this enforcement
even if it is just Jericho Mountain
who's going to say wait night you can
Mountain thank you Mr star thank you
speaking
against you know the disadvantage and
coming up towards the end is everybody
gets to steal your thunder before you
sit
down so um for the bulk of my career I
have built roads and bridges uh of many
sorts State Bridges rotaries so I have a
fairly good command of uh Road design
and Bridge design also a lifetime ago I
was a young architecture student who had
to sit through Statics and strength
materials steel Design One steel design
two concrete one concrete 2 and
indeterminate structures I'm not going
to try to get too Nerdy with you today
cuz uh it's not my intent but um I do
have a very serious concern uh about
bridges um you know we've been assured
that they go over our bridges or the
their I should say with maintenance
equipment and grooming equipment if it's
shared with sow machines that's all well
and good but a tractor pulling a groomer
is probably 30 feet long so at any point
if it's going over a 12T Bridge only a
very small portion of its entire weight
is uh is on that bridge same if it's a
pickup truck or whatever you know the
wheelbase is such that the front wheels
are off the bridge before the back
wheels come on but when you're talking a
vehicle um that um has a five less than
a 5ft wheelbase you can you can have
three of those on one bridge and if
you've increased the dead weight to 3500
by the time you fuel it oil it at a
spear tire and any other conveniences
and put six fat jolly men like me in the
top of that thing you're well over 6,000
lb I weigh 300 lb put six of me on top
of one of those vehicles and imagine
what what that does to a small bridge
that has not been raided by any
engineering agency or any dot engineer
and so um as a uh snow machiner I had
been over many of those bridges and sort
of held my breath and prayed while I
went across and my snow machine weighed
considerably less than what we're
talking about now my my Hyundai weighs
less than uh 3500 lb and uh so uh my
Hyundai also have much larger tires it
has dis brakes so think about the
Dynamics you're adding up to uh six Kips
on on on this on this piece of Machinery
you're um presumably not changing the
wheelbase or the width so what happens
to the
Dynamics you want to be going 35 miles
an hour with Five Guys Like Me on a
little vehicle that's got less than four
feet of stance um center of gravity on
that thing is going to perform entirely
different than the 2100 uh pound machine
that we're talking about so we've got
something that's going to perform
entirely differently um being rented out
to people with absolutely no experience
whatsoever um there is a certainly a
potential uh for some uh serious
disasters with that scenario but that's
again an entirely different subject back
to Bridges um um I'm thinking that the
intelligent approach to I'm not saying
we shouldn't increase machines I love
the idea of of of battery uh Laden um um
equipment I love the idea of the
industry uh moving over to fourstroke
engines which are inherently much
heavier but much quieter so I I'm not
saying we should close the door on any
of this kind of progress but I'm also
thinking that the immediate the now
aspect of it if they want to make bigger
machines oh that's another thing too if
you're if you're taking a 2100 lb
machine and making it weigh 6,000 lb
when you look at uh speaking again to
what was previous said when you look at
the change in ground pressure it's
enormous um um there's a whole body of
science called rotational physics or
rotational Dynamics but if you have a
wheel that's about this big the amount
of surface area that all the weight is
bearing on is uh is relatively small
compared to my uh my Hyundai which has a
wheel that's about this big and has a
much greater surface area so yes they
are working on Tire design they're
putting less pressure in the tires to
flatten it out a little bit but we there
is still a potential uh for some serious
damage to uh to roads in my opinion and
if this was a do uh project um I would
be I would be bounced to very specific
gravels and compaction levels and
building a road that would essentially
be capable of taking um the uh the
pressures being generated but we're
we're on back roads in some cases not
even roads and so the potential there is
is terrific and again back to the
bridges uh you know you get five or six
people at Stop on a 20 foot bridge and
they're you know they're running at uh
uh you know 5,000 6,000 there is a
potential there uh that should be
identified uh the US Forest Service with
all their back roads for instance has a
posting uh class one class two class
three Bridges and often time they tell
you what the weight limits are uh so the
forest service certainly recognizes um
the potential for um uh for some kind of
mishap and I I'm not against moving
forward but I think there needs to be a
good deal more thought put into uh the
inertia of these machines you know they
were ility to tip over very easily how
long is it going to take them to stop
with this extra momentum this extra iner
are they be going to put much larger
disc brakes on maybe that's part of the
reason why they're asking for uh an
increase in weight basically is they
want to put a lot more horsepower which
weighs more and then of course you need
a lot more stopping power which weighs
more that's my thought that's just an
opinion I can't offer that as testimony
I don't know that as fact but that is in
fact my my answer to your question about
your question I'm sorry why do they want
to do this so anyway I I could go on a
lot more nerdier about rolling loads
static loads Dynamic loads but you would
all fall asleep I hopefully have made my
point that this needs a lot more thought
before um anybody agrees to it thank you
question Mr
questions one just real quick and it's
not directed to you but thank you for
your testimony Mr suck you are correct I
reviewed the statute and I missed that
that one line I didn't want you to spend
any more time on it thank you you're uh
your chairman no other questions thank
you Mr pigeon you appreciate it and our
against if she's still
here auy
fredman 203 oh okay any more speakers
then on this bill 174
I'll ask one more time any more speakers
on
174 if not I'll close the hearing on 174
and thank everyone for their attention
sheet there are five in favor four
opposed one
neutral thank you very
much and our last bill of today and I
apologize for us going over over time I
did not believe we would have as many
speakers but I appreciate your patience
and staying with us
thanks I open the hearing on House Bill
203 relative uh to coot approved
personal flotation devices they shut
up is the prime sponsor
here I see Captain dunli is
here good good to see you I got two
203 and the prime sponsor is here
representative
McDonald good morning Mr chairman my
name is uh representative John T
McDonald and I represent the fine people
of Cal district 6 the communities of
wolp and tuen bro I'm here to introduce
House Bill 203 a common sense
legislation which require arents of can
Kai X or roolling skulls to wear a coast
guide approved personal flation device
between November 15th and May
15th with five major lakes and hundreds
of other lakes and ponds and miles of
rivers New Hampshire offers great
opportunities to get out on the water
when summer months arrive all types of
boating related activities occur in our
state waters for many years the typical
boating season started on Memorial Day
and ended on Labor Day however changes
have occurred to our New Hampshire
voting season which can now run from ice
out on our lak and pond to well into
December and in some cases even longer
ice in on link basaki was just declared
several days
ago this bill concerns itself with
kayaking caning and Rowing sculls all
three activities allows participants to
explore our Waters and experience the
connection with New Hampshire's nature
however associated with these activities
can be a significant risk that is not
realized by many participants
while kayaking canoeing and roaring in
the scull during late fall and early
spring and cold water can be a rewarding
experience it does pose significant
dangers which require respect for the
unpredict unpredictability of our nature
in New
Hampshire we've all experienced
occasional warmer days in both late fall
and early spring these days often give
false Impressions that water
temperatures are as warm as the year
temperatures but in fact they maintain a
dangerously cold temperature during late
fall in early spring strong winds make
the padding of these type of boats more
challenging and can increase the risk of
capsizing or falling
overboard when you capsize or fall
overboard you can experience a
scientific term called cold water
immersion cold water immersion is a
sudden unexpected fall into cold water
which causes you to involuntary gas
water in justest water which can lead to
drowning and ultimately death another
danger that participants facing falling
into cold water is hypothermia
hypothermia recurs when your body core
temperature drops to a dangerously low
level symptoms include intense shivering
slur speech confusion unconsciousness
and eventually death wearing a personal
flotation vipes would not totally
prevent hypothermia hypothermia but it
will certainly prevent the quickest
onset of it and save your life the
participants Who falls into cold water
will not be kicking their feet and
moving their arms to try to keep
themselves afloat which expends the
needed he and energy to pull themelves
into the safety of their boat in during
a search of US states were similar laws
as to the opposed house belt I found the
following Massachusetts uh boting lots
and canoers and kayakers are required to
wear a personal flotation device from
September 15th to May
15th uh Maine any person riding any
watercraft must well US Coast got
approved life jacket this includes
kayaks canoes and standup paddle boards
uh Rhode Island uh PFD regulation states
that all operators and passengers of
canoes kayaks sailboards kickboards kite
boards powder boards and any other P
powdercraft must always wear a
PFD uh New Jersey before November 1st
between no November 1st and May 1st
anyone operating any vessel under 26 ft
in length including rowboats canoes
kayaks stand up pedal boards sh Coast
approv
PFD uh p Pennsylvania November 1st and
to April 30th any person on board a boat
under 16 ft including canoe kayak Caple
board must wear a life jacket uh
Virginia all canoe kayak and stand up
PBS must always wear a life jacket and
uh Utah all standup boards paddle boards
kayaks and canoes uh must always wear a
life jacket uh in conclusion I would
like to thank you for your time and
allowing me to present this important
piece of uh safe Bing legislation I've
also got a hand out Mr chairman if it's
okay with you to pass to the committee
members yes you can pass that out
representative thank you while it's
being passed out is anybody have a
question for representative
McDonald representative
Taylor thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking the question uh in this
proposed legislation why were not power
included this was something that I
worked with Marine Patrol
uh I guess my personal opinion that I
would like to have those included but
right now we're working on the sailboats
The Kayaks and uh the the canoes uh
excuse me kayaks and
canoes thank
you anyone else for a question seeing
none thank you repres
Mr chairman committee members Aubrey
Friedman I live in Bridgewater private
citizen I speak in opposition to this
bill so first of all how did the
residents of New Hampshire go 237 years
without a proposed Bill like
this why personal responsibility it's up
to each of us to take care of ourselves
to keep ourselves safe when we go into
the waters and you do boating
activities now the issue
of this is definitely a shell wear so
we're definitely talking threats of even
though I don't see any penalties in this
but I'm sure it's going to go uh it
would go to Ru making and then there
would be fines threats of fines and
enforcement and
um you know it's so we're then we're
talking you know clearly uh you know to
take the fun out of boating when you've
got you got to worry you know you're
wearing the the uh life jacket this
whole in enforcement thing so the basic
question comes down to is it is it the
proper role of government to take care
of uh the residents to keep us safe or
is it our own uh personal responsibility
to keep ourselves safe when we go about
and uh you know do Recreation or or
whatever the state or us and I say it
should be up to the individuals the
residents to determine they know their
level of skill when they go and do
boating they can check the temperature
of the water can check the weather
conditions also the size of the body of
water that they're going into and the
speed and they can decide do I they need
to wear the is it worth it or not
they're not a baby um and so I think
that's the whole point is who's resp
responsible for keeping us safe us or or
the state and I say it's us and that
this bill actually goes against the New
Hampshire Live Free or Die uh spirit
it's it's basically Nanny State and
those are the reasons I oppose the belt
any questions for Mr
freeden seeing none thank you for your
testimony and the last pink card uh
good afternoon Mr chairman honorable
members of the committee uh it's good to
see you uh familiar faces and and those
new faces uh your committee is one that
Marine Patrol visits often and uh I look
forward to seeing you on a regular basis
uh I come to you today uh my name is Tim
Dunley and I'm the retired Captain uh of
the Marine Patrol unit and currently
employed as a program specialist and a
legislative liaison for the Marine
Patrol I come to you today in support of
this bill uh as here in New Hampshire we
recognize uh that our statistics for
freshwater drownings particularly as
they relate to uh paddlecraft in our
state reflect the statistics that we see
Nationwide in that over 80
3% of the people who drowned as a result
of a boat accident meaning the boat was
initially the platform for their
activity over 83% of those folks were
not wearing life jackets and in fact
that 83% applies to these types of craft
specifically
paddlecraft over 78% were not wearing
life jackets when they
passed uh hold water immersion as
representative McDonald mentioned is a
phenomenon that most people who who uh
are ignorant and that's not a negative
connotation who are ignorant to boating
and paddling they can go to a big box
store for $150 walk away with a kayak or
standup paddle board and not have any
knowledge of the dangers that exist they
are not required to take boating
education courses like our power boers
and so they they strike out on the water
and when that water starts dropping
below temperatures of 50° and
colder it is amazing how quickly and
they don't know how quickly Mother
Nature will take away the use of their
arms and their legs it's the it is the
uh rapid onset of hypothermia in that
cold water that takes those necessary
bodily functions away from
self-rescue and so often I have seen
over over the years in my career where
First
Responders are within sight of victims
who have fallen through the ice or have
capsized in a paddlecraft before the ice
comes into our Waters and and they just
don't have the ability to keep
themselves on the surface where with a
life jacket not a bulky one I have
examples of life jackets now technology
makes it comfortable they're not
intrusive and will allow that person to
remain on the surface whether they're
suffering from hypothermia or not that
much longer for First Responders to get
to them uh it's as a result of this and
and looking at the scientific facts that
exist with with how many people we can
save and I know particularly the last
few years in our state it's been the
concern of the legislature it's been the
concern of the governor's office and the
department of safety with the number of
drownings that we are
experiencing and so often many of them
are during that cold water season thus
the dates that have been presented in
this bill from representative McDonald
before you and I encourage you to uh
support it I'm happy to answer an ENT
any questions you may
have yes representative Brun Bridal
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my uh question uh was the New
Hampshire Marine Patrol consulted in the
um when this when this bill was first
drafted like the the Inception of this
Bill yes we were yes sir uh follow if
you don't mind um I represent Hampton we
we have a lot of paddle boarding standup
paddle boarding in the marsh I noticed
that that um specific activity is
omitted from this uh version of this
legislation is this a piece of
legislation if past you intend on
following up on in the future to include
maybe other paddle Sports to to more
clearly Define that would be included in
this I think it's safe to say that that
Marine Patrol and the department of
safety uh would be open to any uh
changes or advancements in making sure
that people on our waterways are safe uh
if if representative McDonald saw this
as a as a first attempt to bring
awareness to what is happening in other
states with seasonal life jacket wear um
certainly we would be behind any safety
measure that is just going to keep uh
people on the water alive it's it's
important to to realize and I know i'
I've had some people in the hallway say
well it's you know motorcycle helmet
seat seat belts the surface of the water
is such an unforgiving environment you
can become involved in an automobile
accident and if you're injured and
thrown from the vehicle You're On Solid
Ground on a boat you're not and uh the
the water is just so unforgiving and and
people are just so unsuspecting uh when
situations representative
Vale thank you Mr chair um thank you
Captain for taking my um my question um
I'm looking at those flotation devices
you have there and they look extremely
comfortable and they perhaps wouldn't
interfere with paddle Sports in any way
could you tell me how both of them work
particularly the smaller one that looks
extremely
comfortable thank you very much for your
question yes I'd be happy to this is
essentially a fanny pack that one would
wear around their waist um you will see
on the front of it it has a yellow tab
it is equipped with a small CO2 air
cartridge inside here you simply uh pull
this cord
it inflates into the typical horseshoes
type design that most life people are
familiar with when they think of a life
jacket it is inflated in front of your
chest you simply put your head around it
and there's a plastic Buckle that you
you you snap across your chest it has a
little air valve on the side so you can
regulate the inflation um if the the
warm sun and the summer is beating on it
you can let a little air out or you can
fill it up uh and and that's all there
is to it uh this type of device is again
an inflatable it's more of a suspender
style that you would wear around your
neck um Buckle it in the front you pull
the tab it's already around your neck it
inflates up uh into a uh um a bright
material and if you've encountered a
marine patrol officer on patrol by
Department policy we are required when
we are underway on the boat
to wear these at all times to set the
example for the public and this just
inflates around your
neck um and will keep you at the surface
uh it comes with an emergency whistle to
bring attention to people if uh if
you're out alone again the air valve to
be able to regulate the pressure um when
you're through with it you simply
deflate it fold it back up put a new CO2
cartridge in it which is about $12 and
any other questions for the captain
representative Sergeant thank you Mr Mr
chairman Captain do you know the
statistics how many drowning deaths from
these particular uh boats or kayaks
canoes throwing skulls are we dealing
with the
year representative I would be happy to
provide you with um uh both National
statistics and stateus statistics if
you'd like if you if you'd like a
specific date range number of years for
me to go back I'd be happy to get those
to you off the top of my head I am not
familiar you do the committee I'd be
happy to provide that to the entire
committee if you wish that would be
great thank you
Captain representative Davis thank you
Mr chair and thank you Captain for
taking my question I I've got a my my
question is this I live on Cedar Pond
and we have a pontoon boat and I was
under the understanding as long as you
had a flotation device with you you did
not have have to wear it I I don't know
if that's correct is that is that right
thank you for the question
representative yes unless you are 12
years of age and under uh as long as you
have a Coast Guard approved life jacket
uh within Arms Reach or or Within Reach
readily available is the technical term
uh that is acceptable you are not
required to wear it uh 12 and under you
do need to wear one okay one follow up
thank you uh so so right now to be in a
canoe or a kayak you do not even need to
have one with you is that is that right
you would need to have one with you you
are not required to wear it and so what
this bill does is requires you to wear
it this this requires all people uh not
just those of younger ages uh to be
wearing the life jacket when you're on
that type of a
device uh from from the dates uh
November 15th to May 15th cold water
season yeah thank
you any other questions for the
C seeing none thank you Captain for your
testimony thank you for your I don't
have any more pink cards is there anyone
in the audience that wishes to speak on
House Bill 203 I'll ask for the second
time any other speakers on House Bill
203 seeing none I'll close the hearing
on House Bill 203 I'll remind the and
the blue sheets yes very good thank you
representative Mr chair we have one in
favor one in favor okay so I just wanted
to remind uh look at your legis of email
uh next week's uh Committee hearing is
on six bills we start at 10:00 and there
is a lunch break next
week thank you very much appreciate
everybody's attention today have safe
ride
today you got time you got to go
back thank you for opening that window
that was